I'm going to call to order the meeting
of the uh house Judiciary Committee and
uh please uh rise and join me in Pledge
of
Allegiance I pledge allegiance to the
flag of the United States of America to
the Republic for stands one nation under
God
all right
um I'm going to open the hearing uh on
uh House Bill
1589 establishing a veterans treatment
court and I'm going to recognize first
uh representative Michael mck Prime
m
thank you Mr
chair uh it's good to be here and glad
to see folks who could come in despite
the weather for the record uh I am
representative Mike Moffett representing
miramac District 4 the lovely towns of
Canterbury in
Lowden uh the the Genesis for this
measure occurred at an ncsl conference
National um Convention of state
legislators uh where I I did attend a
panel discussion on this this subject of
veterans courts uh along with the chair
here The Honorable representative from
wendam uh and we learned that several
other states have established fictions
so this of course raises the question as
to why
veterans um in some cases May rate their
own Court should a veteran guilty of a
felony domestic violence say be treated
differently than a civilian who is uh
similarly convicted of the same crime
so we we do have a history of of
multi-tier Justice options so to speak
as you all probably know better than me
if a veteran was on active duty military
person was on active duty he could face
a military Court marshal for alleged
misconduct where the consequences could
be better or worse uh than what might
occur in a civilian court but a
discharged veteran in legal Peril is at
the mercy of of Civilian Justice for
better for worse
so should his veteran or her should his
or her veteran status matter when it
comes to adjudication and sentencing and
many of us say yes uh extend extenuating
and mitigating circumstances have long
come into play when passing sentences on
convicted felons so should military
service be considered extenuating or
mitigating maybe so full disclosure I am
a veteran I chair the house veterans
committee here as you probably know um
and I have served obviously with many
veterans over the many years to include
some Vietnam veterans and uh and I'm
quite aware of how many of them Vietnam
veterans in particular and other
Veterans as well uh ended up in legal
trouble following their service
especially if they were In Harm's Way uh
in combat
situations in 1998 almost 60,000 Vietnam
War veterans
were incarcerated
60,000
Nationwide so sending 19y olds into
Harm's Way To Suffer family separation
mortal danger uncertainty uh the
brutalizing experience of combat is is
setting Folks up for for trouble later
on so most veterans whether the
experience
okay especially if they have support
structures involving friends and and
family and Faith but some do not have
those support
structures and some mostly young men get
broken physically Andor emotionally and
so they're subsequently at higher risk
for destructive Behavior to include
criminal
Behavior so should a combat veteran who
beats up his wife be treated differently
than a civilian who beats up his wife
just to use that come back to that
example and that's really the nub of the
question here so establishing a veterans
court by definition would involve
different penalty options but to be
clear our justice system depends on
accountability and consequences for
criminal Behavior even if it's not
always perfectly me it out someone who
joins a military and sacrifices their
personal sovereignty for their country's
greater good does rate in my view uh
some unique attention when they are
broken during their service to their
country and this is not to excuse
criminal Behavior at all but unique
sentencing options through a veterans
court that limit or reduce incarceration
has has could have its value so we
already have so-called drug
courts and the purpose of which is to
meet out appropriate punishment while
also seeking to reduce incarceration and
recidivism with all the accompanying
expenses that go with those so
sentencing options that can involve
punishments and sanctions while also
providing treatments while reducing jail
time just makes sense for everybody so
HB 1589 seeks to apply the the drug
court concept to uh veterans and with a
veterans
court um and many veterans uh as with
drug courts many veterans struggle with
addiction situations as well as PTSD
physical wounds and scars emotional
scars and uh and all the other baggage
associated with family separation
extended time in life or death
situations there so there already are
some some veteran Court type options in
New Hampshire but there are
gaps and there's a need to better Define
Justice options to fill those gaps and
that's the purpose of
1589 uh the chair and I did meet with
some legal experts uh New Hampshire
legal experts on this subject who had
some ideas about improving some of the
language and I expect that this may
result in in some amending language I
would anticipate and that of course is
the business of this committee um I
forwarded some information the committee
already including a message from Kathy
Kathy Corey Fox uh an attorney um and
she represents Harbor care as well as
New Hampshire Bar Association and I
forwarded I emailed the committee
members uh some language um
recommendations um to change three words
on page three line6 to better
Define veteran what what which is
important what is what is a veteran and
finally as a veteran I will say that our
country generally does a a very
creditable job in taking care of those
who who've dawned our country's
uniform um and inevitably there are
veterans who have never been in harms
Harm's Way and this is something that we
need to acknowledge that there are those
veterans who sometimes take advantage of
the of the support that's out there for
veterans some veterans who've Never Been
In Harm's Way uh it troubles me when
they when they claim uh PTSD for example
when they they've never left the
country um so that's that's those folks
who do embellish their situations and
exploit their veteran status when it
suits them that's something that will
need to be U dealt with individually
down the road there'll always be that
small percentage of uh Gamers so to
speak so we have to trust it decision
makers will fairly and fully evaluate
veterans uh seek those veterans are
seeking extend based on their service
and the veterans who don't rate
mitigation uh do not receive it so there
you have it and I'd be happy to try to
answer any questions if if there are
any questions from members of the
committee representative tur
yeah thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking the question um you actually
focused on the the section of the bill
that I I drew my attention when I read
it which is uh page three the definition
of veterans and I want to ask about part
C of that where it says um a current or
former contractor of the United States
Department of Defense um that was the
part of it that I I struggled because it
seems like it has the potential to
greatly expand the pool of of people
that would uh fall into this while
stretching sort of the the concept that
I think you were just talking about so
could you talk to that a little bit sure
that's a great question that's why the
the definition of veteran and and who
would qualify really matters it's a
great question and and contractors uh
aren't necessarily your traditional type
of uh service person um but with a
contractor who has been hired by the
government to work to help uh military
operations uh and and suffers and the
consequence of that service would they
rate this uh I'll give you in a quick
example I was in Afghanistan and I uh by
necessity needed
interpreters um because I didn't speak
the languages there uh and I actually uh
became very good friends with
African-American interpreter we actually
wrote a book together in fact I talked
to him yesterday uh and so these perss
as we call them uh we're not traditional
uh American Service people but they wore
our uniform they were uh incredibly
important to our mission and uh when
when folks like those get broken they
may even be need more uh assistance or
understanding than the traditional
veterans who are locked into like the
health system and the retirement system
and the benefit system so uh the these
contractors there's contractors of All
Sorts who help with our missions so
that's something uh that again that's a
great question and as the committee
moves this forward um the the role
that veterans courts might play for
contractors needs to be better defined
and there are some other folks going to
testify after me that are uh could speak
to that as well um so there is a need
for some definition great question
and hopefully that helps answer a little
bit other yes representative Greece
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative when a military person on
active duty uh does something out in the
civilian community and is charged by
civilian law enforcement may also face
at
simultaneously
charges within the
military they're inde dependent of each
other the UCMJ is different from civil
law would this allow a service member to
be represented in the civilian veterans
court by the same Jag
lawyer uh would would there be any
cooperation would there be any appetite
for allowing that because when a when a
service member has to have not only Jag
representation but also civilian
representation and you have to get
evidence or
whatever communication between the two
plus the expenses that may be
prohibitive for that service member
especially when he may be junior
enlisted so would there be any appetite
for allowing That Jag even they're not
even if that That Jag is not a rep a
member of the New Hampshire bar to be
able to participate and represent the
same service member in the veterans
court that's another excellent question
uh and you all heard the question has to
do with uh someone getting in trouble
with with civilian authorities off base
uh and the overlap or could a Jag Judge
Advocate U military lawyer uh work
outside the base so to speak so I I you
bring back memories of some of my troops
getting in trouble in town uh and
getting arrested in town for whatever
and then uh and when that happens it
happens all the time of course uh
especially with there are bases um then
uh how how is that dealt with if
somebody's in jail in town uh
then what do you do and and so typically
the commanding officer in some cases
like myself uh or wh whomever would uh
or have to go and bail them out or get
them out of jail so it there's so many
variables though it depends on the the
person depends on the the alleged crime
um and also this being New Hampshire we
don't have much in the way of bases here
here in New Hampshire um so the issue of
somebody who's on active duty
um getting in trouble and then trying to
figure out if a veterans court type
option would apply uh would not be the
same as common in New Hampshire as as it
would be where you have Camp Lun or Fort
Brag or camp penlon or whatever um so
that's a great question I know there
some great legal Minds in this committee
and there folks coming up to uh testify
as well so uh great question it's so
again it's kind of a long answer I don't
know that that would apply much in New
Hampshire because of the lack of bases
that we have
here representative
Smith thank you welcome to Judiciary um
I don't have a great judicial mind so I
need
help who would be the
judges in um a veterans treatment Court
well some the infrastructure for the
proposed veterans court is estab is
you'll find in the language of this
first bill um I
would as this gets developed if it gets
developed I I honestly would uh not not
to pass the buck to the chair who has
has some in I think does have some
judicial great judicial experience um
some of the folks are going to follow me
as well as the chair I I think could
answer that much better than me uh
another good question and rather than
try to answer it imperfectly when
somebody can answer it perfectly in a
little bit um I'll defer to to them
thank if I could follow up we're always
trying to have a more perfect union so I
I thank that uh thank you for that um do
you foresee the need need for specific
training for um the judges and other uh
judicial branch
um support for this sure the language
touches a little bit on that um
obviously there would need to be some
special you say special training um if
some sort of veterans court option is
established beyond what we currently
have uh sure there would be some need
for some special special training or
education or or whatever for those who
are going to implement this option they
would need to know what a a veteran is
we're we're going to Define that here
and and understand uh some some of the
reasons why there would be a veterans
court like the reasons why there's a
drug court so how much of that would be
necessary um I I would defer to the
folks in the legal Community the
judicial Community who uh would be um
putting this together if if it moves
forward Mr chair could I ask one more of
course yeah um thank you um in the work
that you did leading up to drafting This
Were you able to get any sense of um the
range the possible
number of
veterans who um
uh would meet the requirements to be
eligible for this court in New Hampshire
sure we got a broad sense trying to
project uh how much business so to speak
the veterans court might get based on
numbers that we have of of veterans that
have been um you know charged with
crimes before I I don't have those
numbers right at the tip of my fingers
but like I mentioned earlier like in
1998 there were 60,000 incarcerated
Vietnam era veterans so th those numbers
are are out there and available and I'm
sure that we can get those uh my sense
is not is that it's not a huge number um
the the number of veterans who would be
eligible for a veterans court option
should one be developed uh I don't sense
it be that big um but I can't tell you
at this moment I can't project a really
good number but based on what we've had
in the past I'm I'm sure that we could
get to a ballpark figure thank you Mr
chair I just in the context for my
questions I I I just want to say that
when we spend a lot of time and a lot of
money to teach people how to kill others
and then we send them home and expect
them to immediately be be able to take
off one hat and put on another and
function
in our um in our in theory peaceful
Society that's a big demand that we put
on on primarily men but also women and I
am very sympathetic to that and if there
is a way for us to better um bring
people back into society I would love to
find that way so I thank you for
bringing this bill forward uh thank you
representative and to your point
uh throughout history it's largely been
young men as you mentioned younger men
who we sent off uh I was over 50 when I
went to Afghanistan and when you're
older uh you have some uh emotional
armor inevitably we all develop over
time you know and so when you're 19 and
you're suddenly thrust in some of these
situations uh those are the ones that
more likely to come back uh broken in in
need of some um some special
assistance thank you other questions yes
representative Stapleton and and then
representative Lonzo thank you for
taking my question uh two
questions um right
now we're about 20,000 short on
recruitment all
services but if we get into war
um it's going to increase uh the number
of casualties injured and
affected um and if we had to restore the
draft um and go into a Warfare situation
like in Vietnam Korea or otherwise uh
this court can really be of value uh I
would imagine um in those circumstances
down the road in the future that's
number one number
two what using your your experience when
a soldier gets in trouble in
town um what happens is he on his own or
does a CEO come and bat for him and make
arrangements for councel how does that
work sure uh another good question it
depends on what they did you know if
they get drunken in a fight and thrown
in jail which which is not unusual uh
that's something that the uh senior
enlisted in in the in officer of course
uh are informed of um I'm thinking back
to uh more situ more serious situations
domestic violence uh un sadly is not
uncommon uh in the military community
and so if there is assault and injury uh
in that situation which is more serious
and someone uh
is incarcerated or jailed uh it's not
necessarily as easy
if somebody's been injured or or shot or
or Worse to get them out of the uh
civilian authorities and onto the
military base so locally the the local
civilian law enforcement and the base
law enforcement obviously develop a
relationship and again depending on on
the crime or the alleged crime uh the it
it sometimes it's easy to turn them over
to military authorities and sometimes
it's not it depends on severity of the
crime and and the local personalities
and and that type of thing if that
hopefully that helps answer a little
bit J
L thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my um question um so I was just
curious of have other states established
a veterans uh treatment Court yes thank
you for the question have other states
established veterans courts answer is
yes um in fact the uh the ncsl session
that the chair and I attended uh people
from some of these other states that
have have established this veteran Court
option uh described their experiences
and the value that that they believe
these courts brought to their states so
yes um other states do have this
option other other
questions oh yes representative trip I'm
sorry uh thank you Mr chair uh thank you
for taking my question question uh I
believe the number you give me is
probably what for for uh people that are
incarcerated V veterans would that be
Nationwide or in New
Hampshire um well the the one number in
my testimony was from 1998 the big
number nationally of Vietnam erors who
are incarcerated earlier question had to
do with like New Hampshire numbers
incarcerated or that we could anticipate
and I I don't have right at the tip of
my finger so to speak uh really good
numbers I would want to give you on how
many are currently incarcerated how many
we would project would be eligible for
the court not and again not every uh by
default not every military person would
would have a right to to the special
circumstances that a veterans court
would provide some uh it would be at the
discretion of of the courts as to
whether somebody's individual case would
allow them to be referred to a veteran
Court similar to a drugs Court I I wish
they had good numbers uh and we can and
we can and we'll get you some numbers um
but I don't have them right- handy all
right well thank you very much other
other questions so you know I guess um
just maybe I can um I can answer one
question or at least try to that uh
subject I know there are some people
here from the judicial branch who will
correct me if I'm if I say something
incorrect but I think one of the things
that has always been sort of a pet peeve
for me and I I I sort of fought against
against it a little bit uh originally
and then it just became clear that
everyone around the country was doing
was using this terminology so I I just
said it's not it's not a it's not a
battle I want to die not a hill I want
to die on so to speak and that is
referring to either the drug court or
the mental health court or the veterans
court as kind of separate courts they're
not really separate courts in the sense
that we have you
know uh they get a we we appoint uh
judges specifically to these courts or
it's another Court besides the superior
court or the Circuit Court it really is
a sort of a a um uh a docket in if you
will in the in the circuit court or in
this case it would be in the Circuit
Court Andor the Superior Court uh that
would be that would be treating these
kinds of treating veterans that were
eligible um and fell within the
parameters of the uh of the bill so it's
you know it it it colloquially so to
speak these have get gotten referred to
now as drug courts and mental health
courts and and uh veterans courts but
they're not really sort of separate
courts I that that would be U the answer
that I that at least my answer to what
the question that representative Smith
raised the other question I have uh
representative MAF and I'm I'm wondering
if if this might be something that um
you or perhaps the veterans community
would be would be in the best position
answer with regard to representative
tur's question about
contractors um I I I see that the
definition right now says a current or
former mil U I'm sorry a current or
former contractor of the United States
Department of Defense and what I'm
wondering from I I assume from your
answer previously that you would be talk
you would want the the people that you
would want to capture to be eligible for
treatment in the drug court would be
people who were contractors who served
in for lack of a better term a sort of a
combat kind of situation as opposed to
if somebody's a contractor for uh for
the Department of Defense you know
working on making sure that they there's
not a cost overrun and all they do is
all they're doing really is sitting at a
desk at the Pentagon uh or some office
outside the Pentagon you don't you are
not intending to cover them is that
correct sure thank you for that uh
question yeah absolutely uh the courts
whoever the adjudicating uh person is
that looking looks at the individual's
uh conviction when it comes to
sentencing then they would have have to
you know listen to uh find out about the
background of the person as I said
earlier if if someone has never left the
country Never Been In Harm's Way they've
always worked in an office environment
uh in my thinking they would not be
eligible so much for veteran Court
consideration is someone who's been In
Harm's In Harm's Way to use that term uh
but again it be up to the to the courts
and I also want to point out that when
we speak of contractors many contractors
not all but many contractors are former
military uh with some special training
and expertise so once they leave active
duty they are brought back as
contractees uh so a contractor um who
got in trouble as a contract cont ractor
not an active duty uh you know
still would especially if they were a
former veteran um would I think rate
consideration for a so-called veterans
court and ter other other point and you
all can explain this about yeah veterans
court there wouldn't be a veterans
Courthouse per se I think that's what
the the chair was talking talking about
there's existing legal infrastructure or
judicial infrastructure Court
infrastructure that would assume the
veteran Court U assignments so to speak
uh but no there wouldn't be a there's no
fiscal note to build a veteran's
courthouse so to speak
so other other thank you other qu yes
representative
gon is it the intent of this legislation
to only cover veterans who have been
honorably discharged or would it cover
other than honorable bad conduct
discharges possibly even somebody who
was Court Marshal and received a
dishonorable dischar sure thank you
represent that's another good question
there are different levels of discharg
most are honorably discharged but some
are discharged under less than honorable
conditions uh you mentioned BCD bad
conduct uh discharge we call it a big
chicken dinner BCD um and then there's
Flatout dishonorably discharged who I
who don't rate any uh help uh or any
benefit so to speak um that's the type
of definition that that the that's why
this excellent hearing is identifying
some of these gaps in the language that
that can be improved so uh as to whether
somebody who received a discharge under
less than honorable conditions should be
eligible for this uh well some of the
again somebody who uh served their
country got broken overseas got
discharged under less than honorable
condition they may be the ones who
especially need a veterans court um so
that definition needs to be forthcoming
great question uh and I know the
out other questions for this witness all
right thank you very much representative
MAF oh I'm sorry I'm oh representative
St I'm sorry thank thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my
question have you
identified any judges in the state who
are veterans who or who are sensitive to
the effects of combat trauma um that
might be suitable and selective
selectable for um these cases that
you've described for the court thank you
for the question in terms of identifying
uh judges or Court Personnel uh frankly
I haven't had that much interaction with
the judicial system uh for which I'm I'm
grateful and I don't know that many
judges I know a few I know one here so
to answer your question as to what
judges might be in the judges stable so
to speak who actually great question you
know uh I would think that a judge who
who had been a Jag uh uh Ronda sanis was
a Jag uh a military lawyer so a judge
who has that background I would think
would have that would be an advantage uh
in terms of how many there are um I'm
not sure probably the biggest
qualification would be knowledge of of
the law but if there are some judges of
military background I think that that
would be a plus I don't know how many
you all right other questions seeing
none thank you very much thank you Mr
Sher all right uh next I'm GNA call on
Warren
Parry good morning Mr chair members of
the committee for the record my name is
Warren Perry I'm the deputy adant
general for New Hampshire's Department
of military Affairs and veteran services
in that role we provide the services
that the state provides and oversee the
servic pro state provides to all
veterans in the state of New Hampshire
of which there are about
94,000 uh I want to take just a couple
quick uh minutes to maybe help address
some of the questions that I heard today
and then just say that the department
wholeheartedly supports the bill I think
there is some room for improvement in
some of the language particularly as it
pertains to the definition of veteran
our recommendation would be as in all of
the legislation that we see to use 2150
RSA 2150 as the definition of veteran as
it applies to the state it's easy it's
there it's already in the statute so a
veteran so maybe some recommended
language would be a veteran is anyone
who meets the criteria as defined in RSA
2150 and that would kind of clean it up
that's 21 colon 50
yes sir I'm sorry I'm 21 50 uh and uh
you know it it it lays it out exactly
what the state considers a veteran and
it kind of it would clean up you know
without going into all of the details it
would clean up the questions about
discharge uh and discharge status and
you know is is this honorably discharged
veterans or not discharged veterans and
then if there is some question of
whether or not we should consider all
regardless of their their discharge
status then the the committee and the
will of the general court will kind of
figure that out you know what can I can
I just interrupt and I'm apologize but
just I just don't want to forget this
question with regard to the contract you
heard the testimony about the contractor
I'm just wondering is there
some sort of Lang definitional language
that's either in state law or in the in
uh title 10 of the US code that sort of
talks about the kind of uh the kind of
contractors that we're talking about in
other words contractors that are in in
some kind of a combat theater so none
that I'm aware of Sir right so I do know
that you know particularly as it relates
to interpreters right I I served in you
know in in Iraq uh twice in Desert Storm
and in operation Iraq freedom and our
interpreters were invaluable I would
stop what I'm doing right now and and go
find a boo and do whatever I could do
for him uh he was that valuable to me
and that loyal to me but no definition
that I'm aware of defines contractors
that way and most of the contractors
that representative Moffett talked about
were contractors that generally work for
three-letter agencies right okay so
they're not necessarily covered by the
Veterans Administration or the veterans
Department of Veterans Affairs at the at
the level they're they're working for
some other government agent to do a
specific purpose but you know it could
even be more confusing because the
National Guard of New Hampshire which
falls under our purview in the
department has contractors that provide
security at the gates at PE
and the way the bills written right now
they would be eligible for this I would
assume right they would be eligible for
this veterans court so uh you know my my
my two cents are we would leave you know
if I was going to think of it that way I
would Define veteran the way 2150
defines veteran and render the
contractor conversation mute mot all
right I'm sorry I interrupted you no
that's that's perfect but I I would just
kind of leave that alone most of the
most of the guys that are doing contract
work are doing things
covertly the the contract work that
representative Moffett was talking about
so I I would and so as we talk about the
definition of veteran the another
advantage of using 2150 is it doesn't
create separate classes of veteran right
so we we try to say that if if somebody
signs up they join the military they're
they're kind of writing that check and
it's really outside of their control
whether or not they go to combat or they
stay in the Pentagon or do whatever they
do they've all they all have that risk
they say in the Marine Corps every
Marine is an infantryman right so
everybody H runs the risk of going and
and and serving and that risk is always
there so we try not to in our department
create separate classes of veterans we
don't say there's a combat veteran
versus a non-combat veteran we do look
at discharge we do look at discharge
status because certain benefits are tied
to certain discharge statuses so again
to be clear on the first part of my
statement definition of veteran RSA 21
one colon 50 and then no classes of
veterans and that just makes the
language easy and we don't have to go
back and change this bill anytime we
need to change it so again I would say
that we we the department wholeheartedly
supports the legislation and not
necessarily everybody who comes in
contact with the justice system or the
legal system is eligible to go to an
alternative uh uh sentencing track right
so if you commit murder you're probably
going to go to the murder Court track
and you're going to be be tried for the
allegations of murder against you these
these particular tracks in court whether
they're in the mental health court the
drug court or in the veterans track that
we currently use inside of the drug
courts and mental health courts they are
for specific crimes or or brushes with
the legal system that we could find
beneficial if you had an alternative
sentencing uh uh track to go to right
you had some alternative sentencing so
not everybody's going to qualify based
on what they do you know the benefits
are we reduce recidivism we reduce cost
because people we aren't housing people
in our other facilities uh we find these
alternative sentencing comes with
conditions and if they meet the
conditions we generally find a permanent
change in behavior and we reduce
recidivism so there's a real Advantage
here to these systems whether they're
the mental health court the drug court
or for veterans so it's there's some
real benefits here and in these in this
particular case the veterans would be
held accountable to complete these
programs and if they don't complete the
programs then their alternative
sentencing goes away and they end up
being sentenced you know appropriately
by the judge and you know and what they
do so there's some real real benefit to
that so I would like to just and last
before I uh and my statement is just
address something that the
representative gon uh mentioned in terms
of uh what happens if somebody finds
themsel in trouble they're still on
active duty or they're still serving and
they have the possibility to be uh it
the consequences need to be levied in
both the military systems and civil
systems so in the military system it
won't happen right so if somebody's
being tried in the military Court they
won't go to judicial proceedings in the
civil court right because we can't try
them in two places for their crime so if
there is some civil proceeding that's
going in a court matter the military
system may take some administrative or
non-judicial action but it won't be
judicial action so the alternative they
would still be available for the
alternative uh sentencing track in the
in the civilian system but there may be
consequences in the military which may
render their them ineligible for
continued service or reduction in rank
but those aren't necessarily punishments
they're non-judicial or administrative
actions so that's really kind of a
separate thing there's three things
going on you could be Tried by Court
Marshal you could be tried in a civil
court or there could be some
administrative action but you can't do
we can't try people in courts Marshall
for the same crime that they've been
being tried for in a civil court it's
kind of the principle of Double Jeopardy
I would believe so so uh I hope that
answers or clears up some of your
questions pending any questions sir I'll
I'll end my statement I know we're
getting onto time here and I want to be
brief great thank you uh representative
Smith um thank you you really helped
answer a lot of questions and I have a
Layman's question um
one of my colleagues uh in raising the
subject of
contractors um caused me to be a little
unclear about you seem to indicate that
contractors would not be considered part
of this because of the definition of
veteran is is is that that was my
statement yes ma'am so I'm going going
to say we are we are in agreement with
each other so I would say my
recommendation if the bill was to be
amended would use the definition of
veteran in RSA 21 colon 50 and render
the the discussion about contractor's
mood that would be my recommendation so
that my concern I'm going to use a term
that might offend people and it's just
because I don't know any better and I
apologize in advance and that would be
black
water um I want
to clarify that your interpretation of
this would not include people who were
involved in um in
nondirect military
structures that would be my that is
correct so the the F I'm guessing that
the folks that worked for Blackwater
worked for a three-letter agency not the
and the three-letter agency was not the
Department of
Defense thank you very much other
questions for this
Witness
thank you very much sir next I'm going
O'Neal oh yeah thank you here we go good
morning my name is Jill O'Neal I'm here
today um sharing personal testimony and
not that of my employer and I'm going to
give you some context into my background
so give some Credence about what I'm my
testimony today um I 2014 I used to run
the mental health court um for the
southern Hillsboro County um we use that
Court program to Pilot the first
veterans treatment Court um that's the
um beginning of my journey as um my
involvement with the New Hampshire
Justice involved veteran task force that
task force charge it was a Grassroots
membership we were charged with
supporting and promoting programming for
justice involved veterans today we're
here to talk about restorative justice
right so what we want to do is
understand what's driving legal
involvement right if there's a clinical
disorder then we want to divert into
treatment corpse supervis ensure Public
Safety reduce recidivism so we all
support that so Jill um so why not just
have folks be diverted into the mental
existing mental health courts or drug
court programs we need to understand
military culture what's driving right
the iceberg behavior of theory looks at
what we see on the surface level which
is the behavior under sea level what
we're looking at is unique drivers
specific to the military population so
if we're going to effectively address
what's driving legal involvement we need
to understand military culture we need
to have Services we need to have a
support structure um so my journey with
the New Hampshire Justice involved
veteran task force was not only es
piloting the first veterans treatment
court but we were recognized as a
national model I was invited and accept
Ed an invitation by Senator Shaheen to
testify on Capitol Hill in front of the
democratic steering and Outreach
committee to share New Hampshire's model
so we had established legislation to
build a veterans treatment Court um
using best practices the 10 essential
elements of a veterans treatment Court
based on the New Hampshire Buffalo model
and we were in full swing of that and
why we were recognized from a national
accredited organ accredited organization
Justice for vets which is spearheaded to
provide free technical assistance
training and support to either for uh
states to establish treatment courts
veteran treatment courts and to provide
them with ways to bring in training and
enhance their programs so what happened
and why they recognized us when I called
them before my visit to the capital he
said Jill you in New Hampshire you have
it right you serve both VA and nonv
eligible or those that prefer not to go
through the VA so talking and attending
multiple um events here in New Hampshire
and hearing from veterans themselves
when we talk about Vietnam veterans
we're talking about a portion of our
military population that is otherwise
seeking their services outside the VA
system so we don't want to miss them
right we also want to make sure that
those that um are discharged for other
than honorable reasons for which there
was a case in nashaa through the veteran
treatment court that there's a safety
net someone who served a tour of Duty or
tours of Duties that are otherwise
honorably dis dishonorably discharged
due to substance use disorder as a
result service related we want to be
able to serve those individuals too so
I'm here today to support House Bill
1589 with some revisions to the
definition so I went on this journey
Grassroots level to say we need some
ownership I'm seeing this model phase
out our non-va eligible provider lost
sustainable funding they phased out we
continue to to carry on in serving those
that are VA eligible I want to thank the
courts the judges we have judges out
there dedicating docket time this is to
your chair Mr chairman your um comment
about it's not separate courts it's how
we arrange the court docket we're being
efficient and effective with our
resources and so what we did is we
understand as a task force hey we need
some ownership and so I devised a
strategic plan that I'm willing to share
with you today that outlines a
coordinator if we do not have somebody
that's working on this to help existing
programs enhance what they're doing to
bring in training and also to help other
jurisdictions establish these programs
we are falling short we are phasing out
we are serving a lower number than we
should be
serving additionally I presented uh with
along with the Justice involved veteran
task force to the adant general of the
New Hampshire National Guard he said to
the task force skin myself Jill you have
it right you have an impressive
presentation you have a great plan but
you don't have data you don't have data
I don't see the need I don't see the
numbers so we said okay we need the data
as a task force as a volunteer committee
we reached out to the treatment Court
professionals and received the data and
so I'll share that with the committee as
well we looked at Branch who was
represented in terms of the Court we
looked at convictions what type of
convictions this is all Essential
Elements for um running an effective
veteran treatment Court you're taking
data you're applying it to address
programmatic issues and you're uring
diversion in a successful way so where
I'm going to land with you is without a
coordinator dedicated ownership to
supporting these programs which are
highly effective then what happens is is
that we are in
intentionally not having an intentional
referral process we're not looking to
expand programs and we're asking a very
stressed system to make it work work and
while we have very dedic a very
dedicated Judiciary and very dedicated
Court professionals um we need somebody
in a position that's going to take this
as a priority and move this forward so
we have data we've served from 2014 to
2019 that's as far as I could take the
data um we have served over a hundred um
military uh
veterans and um that's a low number but
we have more that we could be serving
but there's no intentional referral
process
um and again this is no fault of anyone
it just speaks to the need for this
position and so I'm here today just in
support of this bill to move it forward
and just employ to you that I've been on
this journey so it's not only just about
the language of who qualifies if you
don't have the structure the
infrastructure to support the programs
then we're not going to successfully
meet the needs thank you great thank you
questions yes representative GRE thank
you Mr J and thank you for your
testimony excuse me in your pilot
program what has been the recidivism
rate so that has not been measured
that's a great question um again many of
these programs were just established as
the infrastructure the beginning
infrastructure and that's the challenge
is we haven't moved the needle in terms
of um and um making additional
enhancements to really running an
effective
program all right other questions for
this witness seeing none thank you very
much thank you I'll leave the
materials uh yes you know what if you
could uh if you could just give it to
represent Ming on the end there and
we'll we'll he'll we'll get he'll get it
around to us thank you uh next I'm going
please welcome Mr
Grady thank you Mr chairman ladies and
gentlemen of the committee for the
record my name is Kevin Grady I'm a 25y
year veteran of our air force a 25e
resident of the town of hookit New
Hampshire and uh this is a committee I
don't get to testify uh to very often uh
I represent the state veterans advisory
committee we are uh chartered by state
RSA 115 colon a-8 if you want to look it
up uh to sort of speak for the veteran
community in the state of New Hampshire
and one of the things we do is we have a
a legislative committee that I chare
that looks at all of the the lsrs that
are coming before you folks that we feel
have better imp p and we scrub those out
there's 20 of them this go around and we
take a position on them and then I come
and tell you what that position is I
will tell you that we wholeheartedly
support this bill uh veterans treatment
courts have been around since 2008 when
they were first established in Buffalo
New York and our first one here got
established in
2014 and then in what would prove to be
my rookie season here up at the State
House in 2017 session we uh moved
through House Bill
652 which was signed by the governor and
took effect on the 1st of January of
2018 that established the framework for
for what we're talking about today with
the veterans treatment Court um we start
out with one we're up to six across the
country there are close to 400 of these
programs across the country so we're in
very good company uh we support this
stuff I I'm sure that on the uh the
literature that you got from the
previous speaker that a lot of the uh
the nuts and bolts how many how how
large how fast questions have been
answered from our perspective whenever
we have the opportunity to improve the
life of a veteran and especially
veterans families we are literally all
about veterans families because our
motto is when one of us serves all of us
serve and if you in fact the whole
family serves so if you put somebody if
you incarcerate somebody who has an
issue then them sitting in a jail cell
and then when they get out that that
issue hasn't been solved and this is
this is an an attempt to bring together
all the resources to solve solve the
problem at the at the lowest level make
the veteran accountable for the things
that that veteran has to do in order to
complete the program and then
potentially uh reduce that recidivism
rate that's really all I wanted to talk
about I know we're behind time and there
are other folks here but we do
wholeheartedly support this bill right
well thank you very much questions for
this
witness seeing none thank you very much
sir thank you representative next I'm
going to call on uh Aaron cre uh cre and
Alex cassal please I'm going to ask you
to since you're both from the judicial
branch and I think you'll probably be
complimenting each other with your
together hello again Representatives I'm
Ain K I'm the general counsel for the
judicial branch and although I would
normally ask him to introduce himself I
feel as though today I have to be Alex
cel's hype woman and say that he is our
new uh Statewide treatment Court
coordinator for the judicial branch
overseeing all of our specialized courts
and he has a lot of have very deep
knowledge in this area so I've brought
him so that he could answer every
conceivable question that you could come
up with is that too tall of an
order slightly only slightly um and just
wanted to uh say at the top I know your
your time's limited uh that uh we've
spoken to some of the judges that work
on the existing veterans track and I
know that the feeling is that they they
very much appreciate the efforts that
the legislature would want to make in
this area to formalize the treatment
courts more and to Resource the courts
more uh so we appreciate your attention
to this area it's a very worthwhile
program many other states do have it um
and we'd love to do more in this area uh
so well all of the the policy decisions
and the debates that we're we're hearing
today are are your particular uh issues
to solve we appreciate the work that
you're doing we think we could do more
in this area in the court system right
so you have provided um and I um I don't
think that all me I'm not sure if all
members of the committee have gotten
this but I know that I and
representative MAF at the prime sponsor
have gotten the uh the sort of redlined
proposed changes that you've made to the
language I I only got it l i only opened
it literally this morning before I came
up and so I haven't had a chance to look
at it in great detail but my impression
is as as per the meeting which
representative MAF and myself had with
the two of you um it sounds like what
you've done is basically sort of adjust
the language to be sure that it's not
inconsistent with
something uh W with some operations of
the judicial branch in some way and so
that it gives kind of Greater
flexibility um to be able to make sure
that this that the the veterans court uh
docket so to speak can be integrated
into the judicial branch with sort of
for lack of a better term minimum
disruption I mean is that would that be
a fair statement absolutely Our
intention in giving you some feedback is
to just to sort of familiarize you with
the existing administrative structure so
that we can fold it in with uh without
duplicating resources or anything of
that nature um and I think that the the
two particular challenges that we
brought to your attention were that we
do have some counties that would have
relatively low participation right now I
think Miss O'Neal's point is right we
can absolutely be reaching out to and
targeting more people but it is a
smaller overall population than we might
be drawing into some of the other
treatment courts and so we just have
some administrative challenges about how
to serve um those counties and we talked
some ideas with you that I think would
would absolutely work and that we'd be
able to implement and the other was just
a more kind of technical funding piece
on how we get federal grants to make
sure that we do it in a way that um
we're not kicked out for supplanting or
or doing something that the federal uh
Grant manager sometimes uh can be a bit
picky about or could lose us the
opportunity to get some grants so that
was the sort of nature of the feedback
that all right um Mr Cel uh please
anything you want to tell us uh
uh thank you Mr chairman and members of
the committee um I like has has already
been said I'm the Statewide treatment
Court coordinator um I've been before
that I was primarily just overseeing the
drug Courts for the judicial branch for
about seven and a half years and I was a
local coordinator of the drug court in
straford County I was in straford county
for about 12 13 years so I have a a you
know history of working in the treatment
courts most of the stuff that I planned
on either saying or addressing
fortunately because four or five people
have gone for me have already been
brought up you know the justice for vets
the training um you know the the target
population whether or not a honorable or
dishonorable uh you know charge should
affect whether or not they are able to
receive treatment um most of the things
that I planned on talking about had
already have already been brought up so
I don't want to you know recycle all of
that but if there are specific questions
about treatment courts in general uh I
can answer them as best I can questions
for um this witness um oh yes uh whoops
M Mr are you going to be making that
material available to yes for for sure I
am and and I I guess what I would say is
um it it it may be that that I or other
members of the committee will may be in
touch with you just uh you know as we
kind of incorporate finalized language
prepare an amendment that incorporates
finalized language um I suspect we may
be in touch with you or representative
mfet may be in touch with you also um
yes but absolutely um someone I'm sorry
another qu representative
tur uh yeah thanks thanks for taking the
question just just quickly um on on the
testimony we heard before from uh Mr
Perry about uh adopting RSA 2150 as the
definition um would that be consistent
with the population that you think
should be uh eligible for this or or are
you familiar with are you familiar with
it at all I was not familiar with that
statute until it was brought to my
attention but the only thing I would say
is we really defer to your judgment on
who you want to include
um we're going to follow your direction
on on it sounds like you do have some
some policy determinations to make about
whether or not you want to include
contractors uh that or whether you want
to include people with bad conduct or
dishonorable discharges that does seem
like a a challenging policy question but
we're going to follow the instruction
that you give us on the population you
want to include great other other
questions for these Witnesses all right
thank you very much appreciate you being
here and thank you for your work on the
with the suggested changes um I don't
have any other pink cards on this bill
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on House Bill
1589 right seeing none I'm going to
close the hearing on uh House Bill 1589
1651 um relative to the to combining the
board of tax and land appeals and the
for
what's that yes it's a a little addendum
or
about
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is Dan Maguire I
represent the town of Epsom um the bill
in front of you would combine the Bureau
of tax and land appeals and the housing
appeals board into a single board with
the responsibility of both um actually
with greater responsibility than than
they currently have jointly and um
I'm going to assume for the purpose of
this discussion that you know roughly
what those two boards do but if you
don't please ask me a question I'd be
happy to answer so the Genesis of this
bill was the budget that we worked on a
year ago and um I'm on the section of
the finance committee that deals with
the budgets of these two boards and uh
when they came to us
in for our overview of their budget um
the Bureau of tax and land appeals told
us that they were flat out that and they
asked for um some extra computer um
software to help them with their
scheduling and so on which we granted
them and and so they said that they were
very busy uh the housing appeals board
on the other hand came to us and said
they would like more
responsibility so you can imagine how
unusual that is sitting on the finance
committee to have an agency come to you
and say we'd like to do more you know we
we're not that busy and so um so that
was the Genesis of this idea was that
one agency they're very similar they're
appointed in the same way they sit in
the same building and so on they act in
the very similar way um and they they
work on similar topics and so so the
Genesis of this was maybe if they were
combined that would be a little bit more
resources for the
btla but but but also we could at the
same time give a little more
responsibility in the area that the
housing appeals board works so um so the
bill the bill itself takes these two
three- member boards and makes them into
a single five member board um now let's
talk a little bit about detail um so
first of all I have to apologize the
bill in front of you is really poorly
drafted I it's it's just that simple um
I got it uh I first read was able to
read it on the very last day of of the
signing period so due to the Log Jam and
OSS this came out like at the very last
minute and I simply had to sign it and
and Let It Go um but what I asked them
to do was to combine the two sections of
Law and since they're both written in a
very similar way I thought they would go
paragraph by paragraph and merge
all the paragraphs but instead the way
they did it was they took the btla
language and essentially pasted the
housing appeals board language after it
you know into one big section which is
really in my opinion not acceptable so
if you like the idea if you like the
concept here um and you want my
continued help I would be happy to get
you next week a a truly merged bill that
was you know worthy of being passed
which I don't think this one is but
there there are two specific details
that I asked the drafters for that they
did not give me um and I want to I want
to at least mention those because even
if you don't like the bill itself you
might want to incorporate there are
other similar bills floating around that
you're working on right so you might
want to sort of merge all those into one
big thing and so uh this piece of paper
I handed out um is is an unchanged
section of the law dealing with the
Bureau of tax and land appeals and what
it says is even though they have a
three- member board what they are able
to do is for efficiency reasons only
have two members hear any given case
right so a case comes before it they
could put two members on it um and if
those two members agree then the third
member doesn't have to ever be involved
in this work on this case but if the two
members disagree then the third member
makes the decision right and as I
understand it the housing appeals board
does not operate that way at least the
way this bill is written this this
feature would only apply to Bureau of
tax and land appeals style questions and
not to housing appeals board so I wanted
that feature two people hearing a case
and one person only if they disagree one
person making a decision to be in the
combined board right and it's not
written that way so that's why I handed
this out the other one is um let's see
I'll find the page here um the is the
fee so um if you read the bill they
change the fee for the for this whole
board to
$250 the current fee for the Bureau of
tax and land appeals when you want to
initiate a case is only
$65 well it turns out it's been $65 for
40 or 50 years or something like that
right so it's it needs it's time for an
update um but it was not my intention to
update to to quadruple it to $250 it was
my intention to double it to
$130 and
um and that didn't get into the bill
correctly um the housing appeals board
because it's brand new they their fee is
$250 and and which is the same as
Superior court if you start a superior
court case it's the same
$250 um but it was my intention for
those style of cases to leave that alone
and the one last thing I'll say is um
right now the housing appeals board only
deals with housing related issues it
doesn't deal with other land land use
issues and it was my intention and I
think that is in this bill to to allow
them to to deal with appeals of any
planning board or zoning board decisions
not just specifically
questions thank you for
you thank you for taking my question uh
the last thing you said was quite
interesting uh
because when you tie it in with the
first thing you said was that the
housing pill board wants more
responsibilities they weren't very uh
specific about that were they at the
time yes no I think maybe I don't
remember you hopefully there's somebody
here from from that group that can
answer but but the way I remember it was
they could they did specifically mention
doing more than just housing right they
doing other kinds of
appeals of other kinds of questions did
they have any specifity as to what the
other kinds of appeals would be or
whatever um not that I recall not you
know when we're dealing with the budget
we don't tend
to I understand that but you know since
you are here presenting this bill I and
and if you're asking for example the
bill that follows me is is is along
those lines and I am in favor of that
but it isn't the same it it isn't the
you I'm sorry I have just a couple of
questions um um I am I correct uh uh
representative McGuire that in this bill
the the bill that is that is currently
before
us does not include a change in the
manner of appointment is that right and
that's right right and and I have no
particular opinion on that I know there
are other bills and so my recommendation
to you guys is you think about this
whole thing of the if you decide to
combine them maybe create one bill that
has all the features that you like right
so if you if you decide to change that
aspect if you decide to change the other
you you put it into a single bill um
otherwise if you if you don't like
combining them then
presumably you could have one bill
related to the btla and one bill related
to the house housing appeals board and
change whatever features you like in
those
bills sure okay and just so you
understand what what I what I was
talking about is there there is you may
know that there I believe there's
another bill somewhere that would make
right now that both the hab and the btla
the appointments to that board are made
by the Supreme Court it's you know that
it that has always been something that
has bugged me a little bit because these
people really are effectively judges and
I it just I don't particularly like the
idea of Judges appointing other judges
it seems to me that it makes more sense
for the governor and councel to be
appointing judges um and I actually I
think um that the Supreme Court agrees
with that they're not so particularly
particularly fond of the idea of making
those kind of appointments either I know
when I was on the Supreme Court I kind
of you know I I sort of felt that way
but but I didn't think it was my role as
a as a uh as a judge to be you know let
that's for the legislature to decide but
now that I am here I kind of feel that
it makes sense to to change it yeah so I
I agree with you and I think you could
put that in here the bill itself this
the the intent is about administrative
efficiency not about too much changing
the you know the details right so other
other questions the only other thing I
would say just just for as an
informational thing uh uh representative
McGuire is this I
think if the board if if we were to
adopt this and the board were to become
five
members I think in that circumstance you
the the equivalent of of you know where
you say two members of the btla can sort
of hear a case I think it would have to
be three members of of that it would
have to be a majority other words in
order to have a quorum I think you'd
have to have a majority of the board in
other words instead of five sitting on a
Case you'd have to have I think you'd
have to have at least three um uh
sitting on it because it would be tough
it would seem to me it would be tough to
have less than a quar um well thank you
for the question are you let me ask you
a question back is this a constitutional
issue or is this just something as a
matter of law because it seems to me we
could write it in the way that it's
written now yeah no I don't think I
don't think it would be a constitutional
I think it I think it just might be you
know so so in my mind I think having two
only Mak sense it's it's it's uh I I I
don't agree that that it would have to
be three okay all right yes uh
representative
Smith this is really silly of me to ask
you a question
about quazi judicial matters since of
course you're the expert and I am not
but I'm just thinking of Courts of
appeal where they uh don't they rarely
sit in Bank there might be three five
seven nine members on the court but for
every any given
case there are three members who meet
and there's no need to have all the
judges meet and decide all the cases so
wouldn't that same rule apply
here I mean the concept I don't mean
rule no we could I know we I mean we
certainly could do that that's why I say
I don't think it's a constitutional
issue but I um it I think would
be a difference for both boards as I
understand it from the way that they
usually operate in other words they they
they U they generally don't have panels
I in fact I think the the housing
appeals board I think there's only three
members anyway that's right so um and
and with regard to the board of tax and
land appeals they may do this to but my
understanding is that's not sort of a
their routine practice I understand but
again this but you're right I mean I I
don't disagree with you you're right you
you could do that I'm just uh questioned
about whether you know you'd want to do
that but that was specific me my
intention was to as part of more
efficiency have
almost all cases first heard by two
people if they agree fine if they don't
have a third one okay all right um one
other question I have for you on this is
I personally I think I I like the idea
of combining them I also like the idea
of having the governor and counsil do
the appointments but just one c one
question on
this is there an argument here that even
if we should do this maybe we shouldn't
do it now and the reason for that is
we've just recently established in fact
just like a month ago the governor uh uh
appointed the first judge of the
Superior Court land you stock it would
it make sense to let that play out for a
year or two before we do this and see
how what what the impact of that is um
yeah thank you for the question I
guess I think of the Judiciary as being
extremely busy
and and you know we did add this one new
Superior Court judge but but they still
have a large backlog and so I think by
giving more cases more varied cases from
other planning board and Zoning Board
things to this board that will tend to
draw a few cases away from the superior
court and help them make more progress
on their backlog so so no I I don't like
the idea of
all right other questions for this
witness thank you very much
representative uh next I'm gonna call on
Hudson thank you Mr chair I have some
written testimony sure and I would also
ask for Steve Hamilton to accompany me
because um this is written testimony
from four of us and there's two of us
here today absolutely sure thank you so
you know what could I that's fine if you
just hand it out you know the only thing
I would request is just in in the in the
interest of uh in the interest of
time uh we we will read your written
testimony so please don't just read it
to us again you know what I'm saying if
you have things to want to tell us we
want to hear it but uh it would it's
it's it's not sort of very efficient to
just read your testimony okay thank you
I understand thank you very much uh for
the record my name is Jim ISO I'm Chief
assessor for the town of Hudson and next
to me is Steve Hamilton and I'm the
president of Whitney Consulting Group I
provide assessing services to 16
communities within the
state and the other two um authors of
this letter are uh Scott Bartlett he's a
chief assessor for the town of gwn and
Tom Hughes who's the chief assessor of
the town of molaro three of us not
including me uh a former btla review
appraisers so they have a perspective
that others probably may not have all
four of us have experienced a testimony
at um cases invol ing the board of tax
and land appeals um they're really the
single most comprehensive tax tribunal
that the state has they not only hear
Municipal property tax appeals current
use exemptions and the like but they
also hear State appeals dealing with the
tobacco tax uh business profits tax and
the like um so they literally have
hundreds of rsas um that they are
responsible for the appeals they on and
um they really have a lot of
responsibility they have a lot of
history and they are are really unique
in their setup um we believe uh in the
state but handling tax appeals um I have
attached to the testimony a graphic that
shows over the last 10 years btla has
averaged over 300 cases and um those
years don't include recession years
right so in recession years as we know
um more appeals come out right and and I
believe in testimony you'll see later
you'll see some of those years of
appeals come in um and uh below that um
bar graph you'll see the 32 different
kinds of appeals that the btla hears and
um that kind of um background that kind
of responsibility just isn't shared um
by the housing appeals by the relatively
new housing appeals board um I'm going
to 87% of the cases involve property tax
but not all the cases uh at btla created
the same right an appeal involving the
value of a shed is far different than a
reassessment order for a community um
and uh so while relatively speaking um
the the tax cases there they're quite a
few of them uh the other cases do take
up a lot more exponential time um than
may maybe some of the property tax
appeals of course not withstanding the
public utility appeals right we've had a
whole host of public utility valuation
appeals at the btla and those literally
take weeks and months to work through
and that kind of background that the
members in the btla and members that are
going to come on the btla are just not
shared by the folks that would be
qualified on the housing board at least
in my experience I'm going to hand off
to Steve and thank you very much um so
when we're looking at the
3818 cases over the last 10 years
3314 of them are property tax appeals
and as U Mr misho alluded to uh there's
a a wide variety of those appeals there
is uh um The Smiths who um who are
arguing with the town over whether their
shed was torn down last year and should
be taxed um sometimes these are
relatively minor dollar issues but
they're very important to the appellant
um and they do range up to uh very
significant properties uh that have
hundreds and millions sometimes billions
of dollars in value and uh they take a
long time to process and and I think
importantly
the manner in which these hearings are
held before the board of tax and land
appeals is distinctly different uh they
um they are in the denovo hearing U
process and the housing appeal board is
more of a review of a record of the
administrative agency below and
so the members of the board have to be
experienced in being able to uh hear the
testimony of witnesses and weigh uh
the that testimony and determine what is
true uh fact and how to apply the law to
that rather than the administrative
review of a record from below which may
be um a lot less complicated involve a
lot less
time um the $65 filing fee is a pretty
important uh thing to be considering
should it be more I don't know but I do
know that a lot of the cases that um
small individual taxpayers bring to the
board are over relatively small dollar
amounts of taxes uh to begin with and so
imposing a large larger burden uh May
dissuade people from taking that step
when it would result in a much uh better
them
I would say in in in closing um we do
oppose this bill uh the four authors of
this met the teleconference in email so
while you don't see our signatures on
here all four of us agree to this um
we're also not here necessarily
representing our boards of Selectmen
right so that's why you see no
letterhead on here um we're representing
ourselves as as part of our experience
um and we would welcome any questions of
the committee questions for these
Witnesses seeing none thank you very
much thank you thank
you okay uh next
please
[Music]
sure
morning
big
purse that's why I ask you to sit down
because you know people are watching
they they can't hear you if you're not
sitting down thank you thank you um I
appreciate the opportunity to speak with
you this morning um just a very short
introduction I'm Teresa Walker I'm a
member of the board of tax and land
appeals I was originally appointed in 20
2 um but I've been employed by the board
in various capacities um as of yesterday
17 years um that is far less than our
chair Michelle LeBron um we also have
with us our Clerk and an stelac and Eric
W who was just very recently appointed
to be the third member of the board of
tax and land appeals which were very
happy about
um we listened to the presentation of
representative Maguire and we heard the
testimony of Mr Hamilton and Mr misho um
I'd like to take an opportunity to
address a couple of the issues that Mr
Maguire ra representative Maguire
raised
um he mentioned that the impetus for
this bill was to gain some
administrative
efficiency we've spent the last month or
so maybe a little longer since we
received the LSR and were asked to
provide a fiscal note to try to
determine if there was any efficiency to
be gained and we do not believe that
there is we think um the two
boards handle very distinct areas of
jurisdiction um and they are not similar
other than the fact that they both
occasionally deal with
land um when the board deals with land
it's about the valuation of
land when the housing appeals board
deals with land it's about what a
property owner is entitled to do with it
by right according to zoning and in
planning ordinances and and so forth
completely separate and distinct bodies
of law um well but doesn't doesn't what
somebody is entitled to do with their
land have a have a bearing on what the
land is worth it very well may be in the
terms of determining highest and best
use of that land
absolutely um my background is valuation
so I have enough I have enough knowledge
of land use law to be
dangerous uh I consider myself to be
valuation expert but uh truly would be
dangerous in the area of land use law uh
we're not sitting here before you to
tell this committee that we would not be
capable of
learning um but we don't see the
efficiencies to be gained and in fact
there were conversations with the the
btla by the drafters of the original
legislation that created the housing
appeals board and one of the ideas that
was floated at that time was to
incorporate those areas of jurisdiction
into the existing Board of tax and land
appeals they were very excited that the
word land was already in the title of
our board um and just briefly the reason
the word land is there doesn't have
anything to do with property taxes it's
eminent domain cases that the board
Heroes which are also valuation cases
um forgot where I was going um oh the
senator GA who was one of the Prime
sponsors of the bill that created the
housing appeals board his comment to us
was that the the mission of the housing
appeals board was very distinct and he
wanted that board to be specialized and
solely focused on those types of
cases he didn't and we had a
conversation about
efficiency and his comment to us was we
don't want it to be too efficient he
wanted a specialized board he wanted a
dedicated
board and and here we are now revisiting
that that same
issue the the specific concerns that the
board of taxs and land appeals has asart
from the um the qualifications required
that are different from the members on
both boards um include and and some of
it may be attributable to uh what
representative McGuire said about the
what his words were the poor drafting of
the bill um some of the language in the
bill is very unclear as to what um he
intended and how these boards this board
he wanted how did how he wanted it to
function
um we had questions and and concerns
about the Quorum as you raised uh uh
justice Lynn um we had questions about
the the filing fee and how that it would
impact some of the taxpayers that
appealed before app before us we truly
think
that that the increase of that filing
fee
would deter people from filing appeals
in many instances it isn't going to
deter um a utility or a large corporate
entity like
Walmart it would deter people who are
filing appeals of a denial of a veteran
exemption or a disability
exemption um it would deter people
filing the appeals of um elderly low and
moderate income uh and some property tax
appeals and that's a great concern the
the btla was established to be a
specialized board in a lower cost
alternative and more userfriendly
alternative than Superior Court the
other issue that we have is as Mr
Hamilton mentioned previous viously is
the different levels of review the board
of tax lend appeals is a FactFinder and
our appeals go directly to the Supreme
Court the housing appeals board is a
record review they don't have they don't
take evidence they don't hear Witnesses
um our board does we um if I could jump
in the the um differences between the
two boards are the
timelines Board of tax and land appeals
receives appeals the majority of the tax
appeals prior to September 1 and they
get processed and there is a very fairly
lengthy process of acknowledging them
confirming that they filed on the local
level and requiring mediation before the
board schedules a hearing
the and then someone would one of you
mentioned I think it was you at shamon
um that the
board
um now I lost my TR thought um the the
board acts more like a judge and once we
hear the case it's not over we have to
review all of the evidence and this will
there are days when this table would be
full of evidence that we have to review
and draft a decision that has board
rulings findings and rulings that if it
goes on appeal it would be appealed to
the Supreme
Court sometimes it's upheld sometimes it
isn't it's there are times when it's
remanded to the
board we don't necessarily just sit two
members many many times we sit three
members because of the types of cases if
we're hearing
ever Source cases and there are 100
cases that were filed that we have
combined it may take six or eight weeks
to file to hear them and then it's going
to take months to decide them so it's
similar to the the the Supreme Court
when they receive a large packet of
information that they have to review and
we all have to agree on it um we try to
make sure that any decisions that we
make other board members are involved in
because even if you sit to it could be
another board member sitting as a twers
in a subsequent case that may be similar
and we want our decisions to be similar
we don't want to decide one case one way
and a very similar case a different
way
and we at the back I don't want to read
the the packet that we gave you because
it is quite lengthy but at the back of
the packet there are
four um
attachments one of the
attachments
is the um list of matters appealable to
the board and it's a page and a half
long so and and there are days when we
get appeals we recently got business
business profits and business entity
cases and that was the first time we had
had one of those cases so it took some
time and at that time we didn't have our
third board member he was just appointed
as of um
December I think it was well he he
started January 12th um and we had been
without a board member for several
months the the prior board member
resigned September 1st and the court um
and in the answer to whether or not the
court wants to appoint they
uh advertised it and then it took them
four months to make a decision and
appoint a new member so M Walker and I
basically have been sitting as a
two-person board for probably eight
months
um which is difficult so if you the the
best thing I can advise you to look at
is the filing deadlines the sheet that
shows the processing of the appeals and
the sheet that pretty much I think what
Mr um Hamilton was referring to was
total F total appeals
filed
we we are very busy and I think Mr
Maguire acknowledge that that's what we
said when we went to the legislature for
the budget we don't have enough staff
our clerk is overwhelmed with work and
thankfully she's a multitasker and she
just keeps up with it uh but we were
looking for more staff not more
responsibility because quite frankly we
just don't have the time and we think
that the the cross over on appeal
timelines would have a big effect and
the board would have a lot of difficulty
in trying to coordinate those those two
types of
appeals as well as in my last statement
and I'm sure M Walker wants to say some
more uh we have a docket tracking system
that we set up years ago and it's
wonderful docket tracking system it's my
understanding the housing appeals board
uses team
to keep track of their appeals which
means our docket tracking system would
have to be totally revised and it would
be extremely costly to do it um
so we don't see any efficiency in this
bill we think
it's I I agree with you that it may be
better to wait a year year or two to see
how the land cord is is operating
because our understanding from the
former chair of the housing appeals
board stated they receive about 40
appeals a
year and she has since resigned as well
and the attorney member is now the land
Court uh judge so right now they're
operating with one board member and
temporary
members but I trying to combine the two
I think is going to be more
of a
um confusion more more
expensive we would need a lot more staff
than we have
so my I will say for myself I don't
support the bill I think my fellow board
members agree with me but I'll let Miss
Walker speak from here I I do agree I do
not support the bill I don't see the
efficiency
I don't see any potential cost savings
um and the last issue I would like to
bring up and it's going to sound Petty
but it it's not meant to be
is they proposed changing the name of
the board and removing the word tax from
the title of the
board
um it would make that extremely
difficult for most taxpayers to figure
out where they could go to file an
appeal if there were taxes removed from
the title of the proposed combined board
um as you'll see in the exhibits by far
the majority of the appeals that we
receive are tax Rel or property tax
related and then the other state taxes
make up another decent percentage of
them so I think from a practical
perspective and serving the citizens of
the State of New Hampshire keeping the
word tax and the title would be
imperative all right thank you questions
for these
Witnesses seeing none yeah I I I just
want to take a moment just for for to
stay publicly Mr LeBron I want to really
congratulate you I I don't I'm sure you
don't remember me but I remember you
going back to the
1980s when I was working at Cleveland
Waters and George manast who was became
later became a judge did a lot of
eminent domain work and I remember that
you were at that time a clerk at the
board of tax and land appeals and you
worked your way up and from I have never
heard anyone say anything other than
give you the highest ACC accolades for
your service to the state over all these
many years um so representative LD she's
also the longest serving state employee
at this point in time is that right well
congratulations I really congratulate
you on on your service for State you
have been an outstanding Public Service
chairman Lynn I do remember you I I I
didn't think you would remember me from
when I was the CH the clerk of that
board but it was it was quite the board
and uh George Manus was a Wonder
wonderful man wonderful man wonderful
judge ironically I spoke with him
shortly before he died and he and aab
bean sure were who it was is also a
commissioner on the eminent domain
commission the three of us were going to
go to lunch together and unfortunately
it didn't work out but yes I do remember
you thank you all right thank you so
much for your testimony next I'm going
conquer
you know can I put you ask you to put
your mic that thank you sorry about that
my name is Todd Haywood I am also an
assessor um I have have a consulting
company that does the assessing for 10
Towns and um I'm representing myself
today um I think representative Maguire
um presented the
bill very well and conceptually uh I'm
uh I'm in favor of of
streamlining the process or finding
efficiencies in government um the one
thing I would say is to add to what my
colleagues had said is a btla does does
provide a valuable service and I think
as long as you can maintain that level
of service and then find some
efficiencies I think that's it makes
sense to me
um each of the two boards in question do
have uh subject matter experts so if you
combine the two boards you'll still
maintain the subject matter experts as
as part of those boards not everyone
will have the same level of expertise in
every case but still I think it it would
suffice
so uh that's really all I have to add I
agree with pretty much all the testimony
so far and um I'd be happy to answer
questions if there are any questions for
this
witness seeing none thank you very much
sir thank you uh next I will call on um
Please Mr chairman members of the board
um my name is Philip Sherman I'm chair
of the building code review board we
write the building codes for the state
for ratification by the legislature
hopefully signature by the governor uh I
speak in respectful opposition to the
bill as it's written uh this comes up
because many of the municipal
responsibilities related to building
codes still reside in in the
670 and so forth series of of
rsas um and by extending the
responsibilities of this board to all
housing related matters the result is a
conflict with well-established
procedures for appeals to the State
Building Code currently a person
disagreeing with a local building
inspector or in fact the local Fire
Authority appeals to the local board of
appeals and this appeal this this local
board may be a specialized board it may
be the the zoning Board of adjustment
therefore the the issue here or it may
be the selectman the appeals route from
the local board is to the building code
Board of repeals which brings it to the
state level where we hear a very small
number of appeals each year and the
appeals from the bcrb is to the Superior
Court um this bill as written would
inject persons who may have little or no
knowledge of building codes into a
process that competes and perhaps
conflicts with the local code appeals
board the bcrb and the court I Su uh
respectfully suggest that the proposed
Bill be amended to state that the duties
of this new board do not include
decisions related to the State Building
Code or the state fire code and let them
proceed uh the way other rsas deal with
them currently and I'm happy to answer
any questions questions for this witness
so can I just ask you sir I just if if
we were and I'm I I know I'm I'm sure
that I'm oversimplifying here a bit but
if we were to amend the
bill essentially to
say there what was formerly the uh
housing appeals board and on the one
hand and the board of tax and land
appeals on the other hand are hereby
combined and the jurisdiction of this
combined board shall be and again I'm
this language I'd have to finesse the
language but the jurisdiction of this
board shall be the same as the Juris
ition of the former Board of tax and
land appeals and the board of uh and the
housing appeals board so that there was
no change in other words the the the
appeals process didn't change at all
except that you now both of them go to
this one board would would that would
that satisfy your concern I think my
concern resides in the current housing
appeals board RSA which is being brought
into this this discussion I think it's a
problem today the way the RSA is written
or a potential problem as others have
said this is not played out over time
enough to know where where it could head
but um okay so okay I I see I'm I I just
I guess I did Mis comes from the section
that talks about other Municipal permits
which is massive right it goes to
everywhere okay all right well thank no
thank you for that clarification uh
questions from members of the
committee done thank you very much sir
thank you uh Charles Bolt
from Chris bolt I'm sorry Chris Bol
that for the record I'm Chris bolt I'm a
partner Donna hu Tucker chandela uh I am
a lawyer who appears before both boards
uh um when I first heard of this bill
last week I in a list serve I gave five
words in response what an incredibly bad
idea not meaning to be flipping with all
du deference to the uh to the drafters
you have two very distinct boards the
only commonality is the word
land you have a new board in the
habb relatively new two years by Statute
it has to have three bodies one a
realtor two a surveyor three a
lawyer those are the skills that the
legislature decided were needed for the
housing appeals board to address in a
faster fashion than the court things
like zoning
variances subdivision approvals or
denials originally the bill was
targeting Workforce housing it was
morphed over the year over the time
period to expand it to
General that has nothing with all due
difference Mr chairman to do with the
scope of the btla I have appeared before
the btla for most of my practice here in
the state it I've had uh both sides of
the aisle representing municipalities
and private property owners it is a
specialized board with specialized skill
and God love them they do it I may not
agree with all their decisions but they
work hard and it is something that I
have had cases those big utility cases
where we're representing a 100
municipalities sued by
PSNH it took us
weeks okay and that went up to the
Supremes we succeeded there it is one
where they do a good job it is not one
where I think efficiency will result I
think you will actually have a decrease
in efficiency because you will screw up
the works of what the btla is actually
doing we have the new land use docket as
was previously stated that has just come
into play that is a rocket docket ladies
and gentlemen that is 60 days from the
from the certified record to having a
status conference 60 days from the
status conference to having a hearing
and 60 days from a hearing to having a
decision that is fast that is very fast
that may well take the place of the habb
I don't know yet but it is one where I
think this bill should be
itl I'll leave you with this and I'm not
meaning to be the southbound end of a
Northbound horse but as I thought about
this bill more I thought about the old
Saturday Night Live skit back in the mid
60s mid 70s excuse me with Chevy Chase
and gildner Radner
Sparkle it's a whip topping no it's a
floor polish you're both right we can't
be both right for this board leave the
two separated itl this one happy to take
any questions thank you questions for
this
witness seeing none thank you very much
sir thank you much next I'm going to
please
thank you Mr chairman that's uh very
hard to
follow uh I'm Ben Frost I'm the deputy
executive director and chief legal
officer for New Hampshire housing it's
an pleasure and honor to be before your
committee again Mr chairman I I speak in
opposition to House Bill uh 1651 I I do
want to thank representative McGuire
though for his his openness to ideas uh
and I I think he expressed that um
admirably um he did comment on the the
Genesis of this idea and that was in
budgetary discussions uh last year when
then uh housing appeals board chair Beth
Fischer now retired uh appeared um
before his uh his committee uh division
one I believe house finance uh she also
appeared before the Senate finance
committee and talked about the the
docket of the housing appeals board and
it was her testimony I've so
subsequently spoken with her uh to
confirm this her testimony then was um
not based on the idea that the housing
appeals board didn't have enough to do
and was looking for more to do but
rather it's a matter of perspective uh
that there is there was uh capacity to
take
on uh a broader jurisdiction meaning all
land use
decisions uh consistent with
the
specialization uh with which the housing
appeals board was originally designed
and I I will I confess I was the
original drafter of it back in 2008 I
wrote it for Senator GAA uh and he
introduced that legislation um it's
designed to be a specialized board as
you have heard uh and and it has served
that function for the past three years
very well um then chair Fischer's
testimony was based on the idea that
well should we be
mirroring the jurisdiction of the land
use docket as then proposed uh and now
now it is Law and I think that's a
really great step forward uh we look at
this drive towards
specialization occurring also in the
Judiciary Mr chairman with specialized
dockets in the Superior Court thus the
need for the land use docket to impart
um consistency of decisionmaking in
these specialized fields of law the
housing appeals board serves that
function as well the btla serves that
function as well because of its
specialization and expertise um and I
want to confirm uh the testimony from
the members of the btla uh their
comments their recitation of what
Senator GAA said is dead on accurate I
was there I heard the same comments from
him uh there was a real strong desire
for this
specialization U I think it would be
important to uh give some time to see
what the impact is of the land use
docket although you might recall last
year and I think it was on that bill Mr
chairman when uh Attorney Richard headed
representing the judicial branch said
that with the Advent of the housing
appeals board there had been no decrease
in the number of cases that the suprior
court uh courts were hearing on land use
appeals uh meaning I think you could
conclude that there the housing appeals
board is meeting
a what was previously latent demand for
appeals or access to Justice they were
hearing appeals that would not have gone
forward because of the cost difficulty
of um ordinary people uh trying cases
before suprior court uh it's not for the
faint of heart not that the housing
appeals board is easy
it's not because it applies the same
legal standard that Superior Courts do
but it is a an easier process um because
of the way it's set up and is designed
to be that way and I think that gets to
the filing fee question too I I do not
um uh recommend increasing the filing
fees you'd get some marginal increase in
in state revenues but it would be a an
added barrier to access to Justice which
was the original point of the housing
appeals board so for those reasons um I
encourage you to ital this legislation
but if you want to work on amendments
I'd be happy to assist with that as well
happy to take any questions thank you Mr
Frost questions for this witness Mr
chair yeah yes representative D Loreno
thank you um Mr Frost do you have copies
of your um testimony for us that was ad
hoc I I I do not have I I have some
scribbled notes I can produce something
if you wish representa I'd be happy to
do that thank you
other questions for this witness seeing
none thank you very much Mr Frost next
I'm going to call on Aaron krian please
branch hello again Representatives uh
very very briefly uh this question
that's before you is is not one on which
the judicial branch would appin but to
your other question which is whether
judges should be appointing quasi
judicial authorities I can tell you that
that is not something that these judges
feel is a core competency uh of theirs
particularly because in the statutes
where this appears that the supreme
court appoints a person to a quasi
judicial executive board typically it
also appears that there's a removal
obligation which exists only for the
Supreme Court uh which does not manage
uh or have information about how those
officers are performing uh but which the
governor May and Council may have
information about uh so it is it is a it
is an interesting formulation it in a
couple of statutes and it's it's a
little difficult to implement uh so to
your question of whether different types
of bills would be packaged that impact
the btla and the hab and this this
change in the appointment and removal
Authority is one that would probably
make a great deal of sense to commit
that to a branch that has more
competency in the area and more direct
supervision the questions for uh this
witness I I assume if I mean if we were
going to do that I I I can only speak
for myself but my inclination would be
that if we were going to do something
like that we would have to word the
statute to say it would be prospective
only so in other words any it doesn't
affect anybody that's on either of those
boards now but any new appointment after
a certain date would go through governor
and Council as opposed to as opposed to
the Supreme Court right I I assume that
that would be the soundest uh way to do
it I don't know whether you would want
removal of current members to also be by
whoever their appointing authority was
or whether you would want to
prospectively make sure that all
removals are done by the same Authority
sure good no very good point other any
other questions for this witness thank
you very much thank you I see uh no
other uh Pink cards on House Bill 1651
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on House Bill uh
1651 seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on that bill and open the
16002 and I will recognize
representative
Alexander uh as the prime sponsor of the
Bill thank you Mr chair members of the
committee um for the record my name is
Joe Alexander I represent the town of
gtown Hillsboro District 29 I'm here
today um as the chair of another
committee that was put together by the
speaker
um to address the needs of New
Hampshire's housing crisis um there's
two members of this Judiciary Committee
that also sered with me represented
Wallace represent of D Lorenzo um and
the past year if you weren't following
along I hope everybody was but if you
weren't um the past year we have been
sitting down with various stakeholders
in the Housing Community um developers
planners um State officials
um the whole Gambit um and we really
wanted to get down to the idea of what
little changes can we make to help
alleviate the housing crisis and one
thing that came up um was the fact that
at times um state agencies or or
building code review or different
departments sometimes hold up the
approval of a development over some
small rule um
regulation
that in my opinion if Common Sense
prevailed it would have it would have
been an okay change so um the the way
that this bill is written is to expand
the authority to a housing appeals board
in only specific cases related to
residential um proposals when there is a
state agency or state ruling that a
private property owner disagrees with so
um this would expedite the process allow
the housing appeals board um to oversee
these jurisdictions and as we heard from
the last hearing I believe that they do
have the subject matter expertise um to
expand this to this specific case uh
that allows a ruling of the state agency
so there there are many here to speak on
why this would help the Housing
Community um but I want to speak from
two developers that have written to me
anonymously about this developer one
says even though there's an expedited
review path for the alteration of
terrain permit on the books for Dees it
still takes months and a lot of money
and effort to obtain permits having to
involve fishing game for wildlife
reviews by a wild life biologist adds
time and cost to these developments as
well the same developer says that New
Hampshire do would better serve
communities by not quote over
engineering the process and being
mindful of these facts that these
developments don't have unlimited
funding so in general this developer
says in general Common Sense should
Prevail but it rarely does so this gives
a faster path for somebody that has
a has an issue with a ruling to go to
the housing appeals board can happen
faster so um developer 2 one more the
state agency that causes most delays
with obtaining necessary permits for
housing is Dees he cited fish and game
is the most egregious Fish and Game must
sign off to obtain alteration of terrain
and Wetland permits and according to
developer they have no statutory time
period to sign off and they've seen
significant delays so if you want a
government and a state government that
works more efficiently um I implore you
to pass this bill so that we can
allow common sense to Prevail in these
specific situations result um relating
to residential housing so um with that
I'm I'm happy to take questions there's
also people that are following me that
are experts as well questions for this
witness I guess I I have I I can't I I
can't resist asking you this question
and I and I I hope I'm not being unfair
in asking it but given the fact of your
service on this special committee
dealing with you know the housing
situation do you can you just tell us
and maybe tell the people here that are
in the audience do you have a view at
all on the prior Bill representative
Maguire's bill as to whether that would
help or hurt what you know what you're
trying to do through this bill well I as
a member of this committee I'm not
really comment like comfortable
commenting on that P bill I wasn't there
for the full hearing so I'm I'm not at
this point ready to comment on that all
right all right other questions for this
witness seeing none thank
you
right next I'm going to call on
representative
McGuire
ask asking the same
[Laughter]
question thank you very much uh Mr
chairman once again Dan Maguire
representing Epsom
um I have the ultimate anecdote of why
this bill is is
necessary um 10 years ago uh I happened
to meet a constituent not that he came
to me but I happened to meet him and we
were discussing his situation from
Pittsfield and this um uh was elderly
couple in their early 70s and they lived
in an 1800's
Farmhouse and um their land was such
that the the house was like on one side
side of the land and there was an empty
lot on the other side right or or extra
space and they had gone to their local
planning board and and split their land
into two lots maybe six years previously
or something like what the stuff I'm
talking about is 10 years old so maybe
six years prior to that they had split
the lot into two lots so they had an
empty building lot and they had this
1800s
Farmhouse and it they the the these lots
are on Main Street in Pittsfield which
happen to be a state road you know it's
just houses where this was is just
houses up and down the street but it's
an unnumbered State Road okay so
therefore um they got to a point where
they were tired of taking care of their
1800 um Farmhouse right it was too much
work they're in their 70s and they
wanted to build a ranch style house in
this neighboring lot and sell the the
original house right because they they
were getting old and they wanted less
work right so uh it because this is a
state road they didn't go to their
planning board for a driveway permit
they went to
do all right and do refused them a
permit for this
lot okay and and it's you know they they
wanted a 40ft driveway I mean something
tiny right it's houses up and down the
street there's no sight distance issues
and and so they asked do why can't I
have a driveway permit and they said
well um your lot all we have a rule we
we don't give more than five driveway
permits per lot and and your lot already
has five so we can't give you another
one and they said whatat are you talking
about this is a an empty lot that has no
driveway and do said well according to
our rules we use the
map all right and in the 197 in
1971 your Farmhouse was on a farm okay
and it hadn't yet been subdivided into
all the different houses that it was
subdivided into all right and so now we
we you know it there's so so we think of
the 1971 map as defense ative and it has
five driveways right one for this house
one for that house and so on well you
know this is plainly ridiculous all
right and and the problem is Do's rules
are not subject to Jael car for one
thing they're exempt from Jael car and
and so no legislator had ever looked at
this 1971 rule it was just pregated by
the department itself and and I got the
chair the commissioner of dot to come
look at the situation they went through
there is an appeal internal appeals
process well but you appeal from do to
do right and uh you know the appeals
board only meets in the summer so you
know six months here and six months
there and so on and so you know we went
around and around and and they refused
to budge and and um
eventually these guys got tired of this
this and moved to Florida right I mean
it it just messed with their lives and
and I met the guy maybe four years after
this happened and he said you wouldn't
believe it but dot mailed me my permit
you know and and it was like but you
know it was too late right because they
because they you know they had moved to
Florida so it was like they were playing
with them and then and then they just
decided to you know it was no longer fun
for them and they gave them the permit
you know what I mean it it was
just it was just nutty and and
so and so this bill would at least give
them a simpler alternative place to go
right which would be the housing appeals
boort and I think you know um
representative Alexander used the word
common sense right anybody looking at
this particular situation would say you
know there's nothing to this anyway
thank you very much questions for this
Witness
seeing none thank you very
much next um I'm going to call on um
please
okay
you know can I ask you to turn on the
mic there you go sorry about that
problem at all um thank you Mr chairman
uh I'm representative Merill Gibbs I
represent meramac uh District 23 uh
conquered w nine and I'm also a member
of the special committee on housing
where uh as uh the prime sponsor has
explained uh this uh Bill originated
from matters that were discussed um on
the special committee uh on housing uh
I'm also a former director of the New
Hampshire commission for human rights
from
1981 uh through
um I support this bill uh but I am here
to uh present the amendment that has
just been passed out and to discuss the
the need for the amendment um I did
discuss this with the prime sponsor of
the bill and I hope it will be regarded
as a friendly
Amendment uh the amendment is uh L on
lines 11 through 14 on the paper that I
just passed out it appears from 16 from
house bill 16002 as drafted uh that
since it covers appeals from state
agency in regard to housing it would
cover appe appealed from the New
Hampshire Human Rights Commission on
housing discrimination
cases the amendment that I am proposing
would exclude such appeals from the New
Hampshire commission for human rights
from the jurisdiction of the housing
appeals board the reason for this is
that
under RSA
354a which established the Human Rights
Commission and governs its procedures
decisions of the Human Rights Commission
and orders from the Human Rights
Commission are appealable to Superior
Court and from there to uh the state
supreme court and I believe that the uh
dual jurisdiction that would be created
by this bill without the amendment would
create problems uh this proposed
amendment would um keep appealed from
the Human Rights Commission orders as
they are currently under RSA
354a I want to mention that I have
reviewed uh quickly reviewed um the
previous Bill uh House Bill 1651 it does
not seem to cover appeals from State
agencies but if it were expanded to
include appeals from State agencies or
combined with uh House Bill
1602 I believe it would be important to
include a similar
Amendment
uh also uh House Bill
1651 would uh in situations where a an
appeal could be made either to the
combined tax and land appeals and
housing appeals board uh or to the
superior court that it would require the
appellant to wave um the appeal to
Superior
Court again I believe that this would
would create problems uh uh regarding
the um provisions of RSA
354a and the way appeals from the Human
Rights Commission work the last point I
wanted to make is regarding uh what is
referred to as substantial equivalency
between the New Hampshire laws against
discrimination as regards housing and
the Department of Housing and Urban
Development Office of fair housing and
equal opportuni
uh jurisdiction under the federal fair
housing act a state agency whose law is
considered to be substantially
equivalent can receive funding from HUD
for cases
investigated by the state agency such as
the New Hampshire Human Rights
Commission uh this was true in the past
before there was a change in the federal
law uh but once the uh uh change in the
federal law went into effect and a short
grandfathering per period ended New
Hampshire was no longer considered New
Hampshire's law was no longer considered
to be substantially equivalent and that
funded funding
stopped uh I know that
um this change in
jurisdiction uh to provide for the
housing appeals board might create some
problems regarding the substantial
equivalency issue I know that the Human
Rights Commission uh the Commissioners
and staff have worked very hard uh with
the Attorney General's office and the
attorneys uh from HUD uh to bring New
Hampshire's law into substantial
equivalency and um it seems like a good
possibility that this would uh create
problem that this bill uh would create
problems without the
amendment uh Anie Malachi director
current director of the New Hampshire
Human Rights Commission is here also and
she can testify in more detail about the
current um uh situation regarding
substantial
equivalency and I'm open to any
questions questions for this witness Mr
here yes representative deeno please
thank you Mr chair um representative
Gibbs could you please um give an
example of what type of
um violation of RSA 354a would um be
incorporated into like Housing
Development well um uh there are um
Provisions in RSA 354a regarding
discrimination by developers uh and
sellers of real estate um regarding uh
race sex color religion national
origin um and
disability uh and also
um uh there is a um a need for um
accommodation in order to be uh
substantially equivalent with the
federal law uh that is uh accommodation
in the physical development of the
housing uh and if um there were to be a
change in the way way that the appeals
are structured again this might cause a
problem thank you may I follow up yes
please so for example um let's say that
uh a developer is building a mixed
income Community with
um some accessible units and then with a
um sort of like a um tenant selection
plan or res selection oops excuse me I'm
I'm very sorry um could you speak into
the microphone I can't hear you sure
thank you uh is that better yes thank
you great so um I'm trying to Envision
this and let's say that we have a
developer the developers um mixed income
housing and then they have a um a plan a
residents identified as
minorities excuse me identified as
minorities okay okay so how would would
that be an example like if the town or
well if if there were some activity um
uh that either directly excluded
minorities or in by its effect excluded
minorities that would be an issue where
a complaint could be filed with the
human rights Comm commission and uh if
probable calls were found and there was
no settlement uh it could come for a
hearing at the Human Rights Commission
and if discrimination were found and
you other questions so let me just ask
you would um I I sort of um I think I
share the same uh question or concerns
that representative D Lorenzo had if we
if we were to change the language of the
bill 16002 to
say um final decision of a state
agency uh having authority
to uh
regulate land use in some fashion or I'm
not sure of the exact language but would
that be enough to sort of make it clear
that youan I I I I I don't I don't think
so because um again I discussed this
with the prime sponsor and we discussed
the possibility of whether um actions by
the Human Rights Commission would be
covered by this bill and agreed that
there was a good likelihood that they
would be covered so there's a whole
variety uh which are not directly land
use but which are other types of uh
housing related actions that could be
covered by this bill and I think think
it's very important to make it clear
that we are excluding orders from the
Human Rights Commission and that's why I
phrased the amendment uh starting on
line 11 uh of the of the sheet I passed
out that's why I phrased it the way I
did okay all right other questions for
this
witness seeing none thank you very much
please
good morning uh thank you uh chairman
Lynn thank you committee members for
taking my comments uh my name is Edward
Rogers um since uh 2021 I've served as a
member of the housing appeals board um
just wanted to take uh this opportunity
to share with you uh some of our
thoughts and concerns and and some uh
some information about the board uh with
respect to this uh this proposed bill um
since the hab uh began hearing cases in
2021 we've been very proud excuse
me uh very proud to offer an opportunity
for appeals that uh may have been
inaccessible or impractical before for
for certain applicants uh since that
time we've been proud to provide
applicants with
subject matter experts to hear their
cases um we've been proud to provide a a
reasonable and accessible Avenue for
prosay applicants to be heard and to
provide quick turnaround times so that
applicants can move on to the next
stages of their projects whether that
means active development or whether that
means redesign and back to the drawing
board
um I think the housing appeals board has
proven that the intent of the
legislature back in July of 2020 could
be carried out
effectively the hab has distinguished
itself as the clear root for receiving
an expedited adjudication that
requires
specialization the distinctive
capability of experts in land use
appeals matters um the hab has followed
the proposal of House Bill 162 and sees
how its intent could also be effectively
carried out within the Habs means and
current
framework um I would note that the
proposed expansion of authority uh
that's being proposed here for the
housing appeals board will likely result
in an increase uh in its case load um
however I do feel that we have the
capacity to handle this increased volume
it's hard to say exactly what that would
look like but we do feel like we most
likely would be able to handle it um
those are the only observations I have
to offer on the proposal at this time
and I'd be glad to take any
questions questions uh for this
witness oh I'm sorry represent CH just
in general do do you have a position oo
oppos are supportive of it uh we support
the
bill other question so you know can I
ask you a question that comes to mind in
light of the testimony of the last
witness certainly as I I mean it sounds
like from from both the sponsors
testimony and and what everybody else
has said that one of the things that um
this bill would allow if
the um if we were to pass it uh wither
without the amendment uh proposed by the
prior witness would be that the housing
appeals board would hear and decide
appeals from the Department of
Environmental Services if they related
to a Housing Development is that
correct d yes yes right and so I guess
what
I'm
my to be honest with you this is this is
in some sense a political question but I
think it's an important one as I
understand the way the appeals process
from Dees currently works is that they
make if somebody at Dees makes a final
decision the commissioner or whatever it
then goes to either depending on the
kind if it's if it involves water or air
or um uh uh uh ground groundwater
pollution or something like that it goes
to the uh the council the council that
deals with that particular kind of of uh
matter who is composed
of a significant number of individuals
who are appointed to serve on those
councils
and because of my involvement in another
bill that deals with that dealed with
dealt with proposes to deal with
changing the appeals uh appeals process
and environmental cases my understanding
is that there that those those
counselors I mean those people that are
appointed that to those councils are
very very invested in remaining as
members of the think it very strongly
that those councils should continue to
exist so I guess my question is have you
given any thought
to um what kind of a firestorm this may
create if we were to uh if we were to
replace those councils with just the
housing appeals
board I'm afraid I'm gonna have to leave
it to the committee to uh decide which
process is best uh I'm not here to
comment on that
today uh I would only suggest that
um this is this is a bill that if
approved would affect us and uh we feel
like we could manage the additional
Authority um and we would support it in
its current form without uh without
suggesting anything uh positive or
negative about about the current process
all right all right thank you uh
representative Smith thank you Mr chair
this is a question for
you did I
misunderstand either the bill or you so
tell me where I'm wrong CU clearly I've
misunderstood something
I thought that the
ability um
to protest a decision of a state
agency um before the board is uh limited
to those people who are questioning the
decision of the state agency I don't see
that the state agency would have the
right to
appeal oh no well no you I no I think
you may I I'm not I was that was not the
point that I was getting though yeah I
don't I think you're probably right on
that but my my point was I think under
the current system if somebody is
unhappy with some a decision of
Dees they have to go to the to the for
example the wetlands count for example
let's say that there let's say that the
um Dees says there's a proposal for
Housing Development and Dees says no
this is Wetlands you can't you can't
build there um my understanding is that
the the the person who's unhappy with
that would have to go to the I think
it's called the wetlands Council which
consists of you know a whole bunch of
people who would make the decision and
then that could be appealed to the
Supreme Court and my only concern
was as I said my understanding
understanding is that there's there is a
very strong for lack of a better term
Lobby that thinks that those that
process is you know is fine and dandy
and I'm not I don't I don't express any
opinion on that but um that that I was
really asking you if you know if that if
if you had had any discussion or if
you're people who support the bill had
had any discussion with with the people
who have who support that Lobby because
my impression is that that would be you
know that that would be quite a quite a
fight over what what was the right
answer we haven't had any any of those
discussions uh with anyone and I I would
uh I would leave it to the committee to
uh to explore that further no I
appreciate that all right other
questions for this witness seeing none
thank you uh thank you Ben thank you Ben
Frost
please
thank you Mr chairman and hello again
Ben Frost I'm the deputy director and
chief legal officer at New Hampshire
housing um speaking in favor of House
Bill 1602 I'll be very brief I know
you're way behind time um I acknowledge
the amendment profer by representative
Gibbs uh no objection to that I
understand there is a particular process
that's followed there I think you're
likely also to hear uh testimony uh that
expresses concerns from similar uh
similarly situated uh others with with a
similar pellet structure and I think
there may be opportunity to find uh
appropriate amendments uh to this this
bill that would accommodate those those
processes uh Mr chairman with regard to
the the wetlands Council and the water
Council and I think it's the air
Resources Council at the yes um I I
think there may be also opportunity
there to find appropriate um uh
amendment to accommodate those interests
although I appreciate your political
sensitivities on that point um I'll note
that this legislation is really geared
toward um the the sort of story that you
heard from representative Maguire uh and
to impart necessary efficiencies in
process uh that that are sometimes
lacking in our state agencies um I make
no characterization about the hard work
that state employees do uh they are
serving us all and admirably well but
sometimes things don't go the way they
should and there should be an
opportunity for people to have access to
some appeals mechanism uh that will deal
with their uh concern appropriately uh
and expeditiously and the housing
appeals board does that that uh with the
work that it does um I'll note um Alyssa
marglin had also signed in to testify
she had to leave for another meeting I
do have written testimony from her that
I will distribute to the committee that
would be great thank you I'll be happy
to take any questions if there are any
questions for this witness seeing none
thank you very much next I'm going to
please
Mr chair uh members of the committee
I'll be respective of your time and not
repeat my comments from uh HB
1651 uh but the conclusion still stands
I hope that there's a way to exempt uh
building and fire code issues from this
procedure that being said I don't think
we would particularly be averse if uh
this board was the appeal from our board
uh currently the appeal is to the
superior court and if on housing issues
it went to this board I I don't think
that would be a problem for us I'll
leave it at that questions for this
you next I'm gonna call on um William
mckin
please concerns board and I'd rather
notat I I appreciate thank you very much
I appreciate I appreciate that all right
um uh next uh miss m from the Human
please uh good morning Mr chair and
members of the committee um so
representative Gibbs uh I'm Anie Malachi
from the Human Rights Commission um
representative Gibbs spoke eloquently
about the concerns relative to the
commission and the commission's process
the only thing I would add to that is uh
I believe in 2000 is when the commission
lost the HUD contract because the
commission well because the laws against
discrimination relative to housing were
not uh in sync they were not
substantially equivalent with the
federal housing act um and there have
been several attempts over the course of
the last we'll say 21 years um to make
those changes and that did not happen in
2021 um excuse me with consensus of
quite a few stakeholders the uh
legislation was adopted and part of the
statute now and currently we are working
with HUD to move forward in the process
regarding a HUD contract so if there are
any questions specific to that questions
for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
thank you oh you know what I did forget
to say that I of course with what
representative Gibbs said that if the
amendment is not accepted in terms of
carving out the commission then we would
not be in substantial equivalency and we
would not be able to continue forward
with a HUD
contract thank you thank
you uh Joanie um McIntyre please if I I
correctly yes you are thank you um good
morning my name is Joanie McIntyre I'm a
a broker um here in conquer at cobal
Banker J hampy Associates and I'm also
the 2024 president of the New Hampshire
Association of Realtors the Realtors
would encourage you support HB
6602 the housing appeals board was cre
created to provide faster and therefore
less expensive option for property
owners to appeal decisions from local
Municipal boards property owners have
always had the right to appeal to the
superior court but that's often a slow
and uous process the housing and Fields
board has been a great success decisions
come quicker for both the property
owners and the
municipality just like in Superior
Courts sometimes the property owners
Prevail and some times the town prevails
however it saves everyone involved a lot
of time and money it is entirely
appropriate that the property owner's
ability to appeal decisions of state
agencies when those decisions impact
housing and housing
developments go to the
habb uh House Bill 1602 protects private
property rights of all New Hampshire
residents by ensuring faster and less
expensive option for appeals from
government decisions some some agencies
may have concerns about their time and
expense of appearing at the hab first
they will find it easier and less time
consuming second we believe the time and
expense of New Hampshire Property Owners
should take precedence HB 1602 is not
asking for laws or regulations governing
land use to be changed if agencies
adhere to those existing laws and
regulations which they mostly do then
there's no reason not to welcome appeals
to the to the hab please support
hp62 questions for this
witness seeing none thank you thank
you uh I don't have any other cards is
there anyone else who wishes to testify
on House Bill
16002 um I I see none before I close the
hearing on this bill however I I wonder
if I could just ask and particularly I
guess I would address direct this to uh
Mr Frost but maybe anyone else in the
room who has some expertise in this area
as I'm hearing the testimony here I'm
I'm concerned that just as uh Miss
Malachi and and the and and the
representative from conquered pointed
out you know I if if if they hadn't
raised this issue it certainly wouldn't
have occurred to me that there that we
needed to uh make a carve out for the
Human Rights Commission um and I think
Mr Frost you indicated that there might
be when I raised the issue of the
Department of Environmental Services you
ra you indicated that maybe we need to
do some
tinkering uh so we you know we carve out
that or make some changes and what I'm
really worried about is it strikes me
that I am generally personally very much
in favor of this be of this bill because
I think for as representative Alexander
suggested would have the ability to to
really speed along the process but I'm
concerned of potential unintended
consequences here that there may be
other agencies other appeals uh
mechanisms that we would be interfering
with by by saying you know if you don't
you don't have to go to the wetlands
Council anymore for these kind of
appeals you don't have to go to the
Department of Transportation anymore for
these kind of appeals I don't know maybe
maybe there somehow there's a labor you
know some development could have some
labor implications and you don't have to
go to the labor department anymore um
I'm worried about that and so I'm what
I'm wondering is um if some people that
are interested in this area might really
take a look at uh and maybe provide us
some feedback if you could before we
exec this which won't you know it won't
be for a little while um on exactly what
other what other appeals processes are
out there that could be affected by this
that we either
deliberately want to change or we're you
know we want to deliberately accept
because of concerns exactly the same as
we had with the Human Rights Commission
so with that I will close the hearing
and thank you um next I'm going to uh
open the hearing on House Bill
1707 and as I understand it we may have
some sure
hey
good morning chairman ly and honorable
members of the committee I'm Nancy
Murphy here uh representing the town of
marac Hillsboro District 12 a community
well known to be negatively and
significantly impacted by pest toxic
chemicals um that including one of which
has been known to cause cancer HB 1707
was written to address challenges and
access to pest blood testing for
Citizens living in past contaminated
communities um rather than take the time
to elaborate on the merits of this bill
I request that this bill be ited I do so
not because there isn't a problem and we
need to hold polluters accountable but
because emerging science and litigation
is ongoing and I believe we should just
let that process play out uh with that
I'll end my testimony and ask that the
committee Grant my request thank you
thank you any questions for this witness
seeing none thank you um I wonder if um
in light of that of the requ
oh I'm sorry yes so any other anyone
else who wishes to testify on House Bill
1707 seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on that bill and before we
recess for lunch um it's in light of the
request to remove to itl the bill from
the sponsor um I I wonder if uh ex if we
can open an executive session and I then
wonder if uh the ranking I I would
certainly be amenable to executing the
bill bill right now and granting the itl
motion and I wonder if the exe if the
ranking member would agree I too am
supportive of that all right um yes just
a procedural question since we did not
notice this for executive committee the
24 hours notice and the public notice I
understand we have your blessing does
that give us enough authority to move
forward the one of the um the changes
one of the one of the changes that we
have adopted in terms of house rules is
if in fact there is a situation in which
the chair and the ranking member
agree we can call an executive session
at the on the same day as we've heard
the bill and vote on it and it is with
that
uh Cil I guess I would say that it is
perfectly appropriate under our rules
for us to do that and can I just ask uh
be you know I I I obviously don't want
to I want to make sure we've we've taken
into consideration whatever any contrary
views that any members of the committee
may have anybody have a problem with us
executing this right now all right so
um Mr chair I would make a motion of
itl
second hang on I'm going to make some
notes here
so and if I could just quickly speak to
my motion after I've moved and
representative Wallis has seconded um
one of the really one of the
legislator's leading experts on this
subject um is the person who is the
sponsor the prime sponsor of this bill
and her brief testimony in which she
requested that we itl the bill um made
clear that the problem is significant it
is real and but at the same
time science and law are proceeding a
pace and it would be
inappropriate at this moment to proceed
with this bill and that's why I'm asking
my colleagues to support
itl right anyone else um wish to be
heard on on the
motion all right um
uh can we don't have our CL can you uh
certainly call the rooll thank you it's
here it
you okay uh Vice chair Wallace yes
representative
Alexander not president representative
Andress not here representative
testman representative Stapleton yes
representative trip yes representative
gon yes representative Cab's not here
representative Perez representative
Smith yes representative Horgan
representative D Lorenzo yes
representative
Kenny representative Paige yes
representative Divine yes representative
lonza yes representative
monos representative tur yes
representative Ming yes chairman Lynn
yes
130 itl prevails all right and uh any
reason this can't go on consent no all
right it'll be on the consent
calendar all right and you want the
minutes well will you write the great
all right thank
you all right
SM
and I appreciate the offer of 10 minutes
but uh the 20
minutes the end of the day will be just
you uh all right well spite I didn't
think it was going to happen but we
actually have time for lunch
[Laughter]
so uh so we will re I will uh call the
committee in recess until uh 100 p.m.
okay
for
all right it's uh
103 or 4 uh and so I'm going to call the
uh house Judiciary Committee back into
session
um and we're going to uh open the
hearing on House Bill
1710 and I recognize representative Mass
Miller good afternoon Mr chairman and
good afternoon honorable members of the
committee um I come before you today to
respectfully request you
itl House Bill
1710 after Consulting with the AG's
office regarding the concerns that were
mentioned in the methodology section at
the end of the bill and also with the
Grafton County Sheriff's Department's
computer forensic
division um it was decided that the bill
does have Merit it's just that I realize
there are a lot of preliminary
legislation that needs to be put in
place before we can move to the level of
HB
1710 so I apologize for putting the cart
before the horse and um I promise you
that next year I will put in legislation
that will address these concerns and uh
make the bill better thank you for
listening and thank you for your
consideration all right any questions
for the
you um so I'm I'm going to wait I'm
waiting for the ranking member to return
turn it may be that we will be able to
exec this bill also
um pardon
yes I think I hope so
I yeah I think we have I think we thank
so you didn't miss anything so you know
what um I I just opened the hearing on
1710 the next bill yes and the sponsor
moved to
iten um on the grounds that after
speaking with the Attorney General's
office and Grafton County Sheriff
Grafton County Sheriff's Office forensic
unit um she felt that there were it
needed a lot more work um oh really and
so she wanted to so am I ever going to
find out what synthetic media is fake
news I think fake news fck sorry I
couldn't
resist okay so um if our how many of us
I think there's I think we have a yeah
one two three four five six seven eight
10 11 we have 11 okay yeah so are you
all right with um I all right so um I'll
make a
motion um to itl House Bill 1710 um is
there a
second all right um hang
on M Mr chair that's following the
procedures yeah that have already been
that are part of our rules about the
chair and the ranking member agreeing
right yes the chair right and chair and
ranking member do agree on this um all
right and so um I guess I I would just
speak to the motion briefly uh by saying
that um uh the prime sponsor of the bill
repres representative Mamilla was just
here uh indicated that she requested
that the bill be itl um based upon her
discussions with the Attorney General's
office and the Grafton County Sheriff's
Office uh basically believing that the
bill needed further work and that
perhaps there was some other legislation
that needed to be passed or or included
uh before this was sort of ready for
prime time so to speak and so for that
reason she asked it it be uh withdrawn
um any other comments on
uh my motion to itl
1710 if not then I would ask the clerk
please to call the
yes rep
Stapleton yes rep trip yes rep gon yes
clerk kab votes yes rep Smith
yes rep Lanza oh repine yes rep Lanza
yes you forgot me sorry re testerman
yes chairman Lynn
okay and I don't like about that is I
don't like giving the impression that we
don't
have sure um all right and I will uh
um through is that okay on the consent
calendar uh yeah I think so yeah yeah
consent
was the other Bill the 1707 was that
going on the consent calendar yes yes
that's going to go on consent too
yeah all right well we've got uh a
little over half an hour before we have
our hearing on our next bill so
uh we have some free
time
I I know exactly not used to being ahead
of the class for
sure
sounds
good
that's
it's 1:45 I'm going to call the judici
Judiciary Committee back to order uh and
open the hearing on House Bill 1256 and
I'd like to First recognize the prime
sponsor representative Mike
moff Senor Moffet thank you thank you Mr
chair it's great to be back in judiciary
for the second time
today for the record uh I'm
representative Mike Moffett representing
marrat County District 4 the lovely
towns of Canterbury and Lowden same as
this morning uh so the Gen for this
measure coming to you uh began at an
ncsl conference I know I said that this
morning and the same thing with this one
uh uh where I attended a panel
discussion on on on this subject of
minor access to uh
hardcore uh internet pornography sites
so interesting later uh I after I
returned to New Hampshire I heard from
former representative uh Susan Homa
who's here today uh who is hoping that
New Hampshire might join other states in
passing legislation that would restrict
the access of miners to to hardcore
internet sites like PornHub and and the
like so successful legislation in this
area by other States including Utah and
Louisiana provides templates or models
to refer to as the committee as this
committee looks at hb1
1256 uh and I've emailed the committee
copies of those uh those two states
related laws there are other states out
there as well it's the wonders of
federalism okay so inevitably a measure
of definition is required for a law to
be effective so what is
pornography what is soft porn as opposed
to hard porn uh one person's art is
another person's uh vulgar blast
blasphemy and there there are certainly
gray
areas uh famously most of you have heard
uh the quote from uh Supreme Court
Justice the late Potter Stewart uh 1964
he TR he was asked you know so what is
pornography and it's hard to Define
because of what I just said that you
know there there's some subjectivity
there gray areas and finally Justice
Stewart
said I know it when I see it
and I I think I I understood what he was
saying and I think most people did as
well but the the the challenge for us as
lawmakers we we need to Define somewhat
Define as best we can what we're talking
about in terms of what is
pornography so the language in HB 1256
attempts to provide a measure of that
necessary definition section four part B
in particular addresses this need in
graphic if not uncomfortable fashion so
the words you'll see uh in that part of
the measure that part of the build uh
you know it's it's a little bit
uncomfortable but such verbiage is is
necessary so the bill has some specific
de definitions as as needed for for
these uh relevant terms um in the
definition start on one okay so
reasonable age verification methods do
exist um and that is addressed starting
in paragraph 8 line five on page two and
I would point out that uh 2019
legislation New Hampshire legislation
which legalized Sports gambling online
sports betting um obviously requires Aid
certification technology and that same
technology to include the the
utilization of uh digitized of a
digitized identification card uh could
be used in uh with regard to this
bill okay and then starting on line 23
on page two the bill addresses the the
Civil damages piece so like I said I
early earlier emailed copies of existing
laws from other states so this is the
type of legislation that is law in other
states so that is always helpful when
you're not the first state to try to do
something when other states have have
succeeded in getting uh certain things
in the statute then you know they've
done some due diligence of course every
State's different but the fact that this
measure is in L elsewhere I think is
very
significant so uh and as always once the
committee receives this bill
today um you know the the committee has
certainly the discretion to amend
language add language change verbiage
make technical improvements of course
that happens all the
time and finally and this is important
um considering measures such as this one
invites scrutiny from First Amendment
Advocates and I happen to be a very
staunch First
Amendment Advocate um freedom of speech
and religion all that uh I'm I'm I'm big
on that as some of you know uh I'm I'm
always
writing Sports columns op ads blog
entries uh I I think that the the more
freedom of speech there is the the the
better now all that said uh there are
limits to freedom of speech you you know
you can't y'll fire in a crowded theater
and all that type of thing and also I
don't think that freedom of speech
necessarily means that youngsters should
have access to to uh some of the online
sites that are out there I think it's
our job I think our
constituents as in other states want us
to uh have some guard rails in this
area so this bill would not infringe on
adult access or use of these sites and
and there's plenty of precedent in terms
of restricting
minor access to uh adult forms of
entertainment you know youngsters can't
go into certain uh gentlemen's clubs or
whatever or uh we restrict access or we
require ID we have for a long time in
terms of uh x-rated or irrated uh
films uh we control that and this is not
unlike that you know restricting access
of youngsters to uh movie theaters well
this is the online version of that
really it's kind of as simple as that so
uh limiting minor access to online
hardcore pornography involves mental
health issues you'll hear more about
that in a bit um as well as moral issues
and illegal issues you know child porn
is already uh you know
illegal and this goes beyond that simply
seeking to uh restrict access to
hardcore pornographic sites uh
protecting young people
from uh accidentally or int
intentionally getting on to these uh
these sites so hb1 1256 represents an
overdue initiative to better protect
minors in this area in New Hampshire and
like I said there should be some helpful
testimony to follow but I would first be
happy to try to answer any questions if
if there are
any questions representative Alexander
thank you Mr chair thank you
representative for taking my question um
I'm I'm just thinking off the top of my
head so a mom and pop
restaurant there's there's there's a
minor going into a mom and pop
restaurant having breakfast and the
minor uses the Wi-Fi to look up pornh
Hub I understand at the end it says the
internet service is not going to be held
liable but is there any language in here
that would say that the mom and pop
restaurant by not restricting PornHub
they would be held
liable that is a great question and it's
something I hadn't thought of somebody
the scenario you just described going
into as you say and pop restaurant
establishment where there is a uh you
you ask them what their Wi-Fi is and you
sign in uh uh I I hate to throw it back
at the committee but that that's the
type of uh Improvement uh that I hadn't
thought of we hadn't thought of that
could uh hopefully be easily addressed
in some fashion if if this moves forward
that's a great question and I I
apologize for not thinking of it before
we put this together well it it's okay
we're we are subject matter expert on
this I like to say anyways but um the
the supposedly anyways so um I'm also
looking
at okay I'm also looking at the damages
component
um I just see hold on where am I
looking um section D2 civil damages I
just see
um shall be liable individual for
damages resulting retaining identifying
personal information I I find that to be
broad so if there's a an attorney or
somebody that can help me give me
information on like what that would
entail um emotional damage physical
damage um psych I don't know there's
like there's a ton of different damages
that could be awarded so I know
represented maet you might not have the
answer to that but I'm asking it now so
that somebody might be able to sure and
I I know this is uh is on will be
speaking of online this will be online
of course these hearings are rated G
usually and so anyone can watch them and
and someone who is watching this who
hears that great question uh maybe could
help us out or or certainly there are
experts and maybe somebody who's going
to testify after me might be able to
speak to that uh we need to have in this
case uh some uh consequence you know if
somebody breaks we have enough Lawes
where that if people break them there's
there's not a a clear
consequence uh so to have a civil
damages section here which we put in I
think is important and uh and again as I
said this morning that the beauty of
Judiciary Committee when we're talking
about law is that a there's there is a
wealth uh representative Smith to
include yourself a wealth of knowledge
to u to you know uh look at the wording
and improve
it good question thanks for the question
Mr chair thank you other questions for
this this witness um I I guess I just
have a couple of questions um Mr maford
and representative maford and maybe
there'll be others that can address this
but um in the definition
of uh material harmful to
miners the my recollection from you know
having read Supreme Court cases in this
area is is that the language you've
quoted does come from you know various
Supreme Court cases my only question
is my recollection is
that a uh in Roman numeral
4 A B and
C my recollection is that those are sort
in the case law that those
are cumulative in other words it should
be material is uh that is covered has to
set satisfy A and B and
C that that's my recollection because um
if that were not the
case if it were a or b or c then just as
an example if it were only C material
taken as a whole LAX serious literary
artistic political or scientific that
could be something that had no sexual
component whatsoever you might say you
know completely lacked uh some so I
think it probably has to be a and b and
and c I I think but um yes Mr that that
is the intent that is it line 12 it's
where paragraph four starts it it does
say is defined as all of the following
that's correct well no you're I'm sorry
you're so that would C that you're right
that was not I was not carefully reading
it but I think you're right you does you
do cover that all of the following all
right there is like see there is a lot
of material that lacks serious lit
literary artistic political scientific
value for minors that by itself could
cover all kinds of things but to add to
combine it with A and B to your point so
better yeah you know as I just as I
think about
it arguably saying all of the following
does
not it could be meant to me it could be
meant to
cover it still could be read to be a or
b or c so maybe we'd have to you know
include the word and there or something
like that or just just yeah
just right just you know we we can
Tinker we could Tinker with that
language a little bit um other other
questions yes uh representative Staples
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question the bill seems to avoid
the obviously the use of the term
pornography and um you did mention uh
the 1954 Justice Stewart I missed what
he said on that um relative to what
pornography was what was that quote what
Justice Stewart said in 1964 yeah
uh it's I've heard this a number of
times in terms of defining pornography
in in Justice Stewart in
1964 said that it he was talking about
sometimes it's difficult to Define
pornography that's the challenge that I
acknowledged a front and he said uh he
finally said I know it when I see
it and I think I understood what he was
saying but him or any of us saying
something and and feeling that it's uh
inappropriate uh
pornography uh that that's why I I
touched on the the difficult some of the
words in here are are hard to read
frankly uh but they need to be in there
so that we can have that definition
Beyond knowing it when you see it yeah
that was I know it when I see it Potter
St
1964 and uh and the challenge is to
Define it better than that so hopefully
what we've given you here is is a plus
what I've already sent you from what
other states have done give gives a
committee uh enough in information to is
the chair set to Tinker or or go beyond
tinkering uh you know do some wholesale
language improvements to make this
something work for New
Hampshire yeah thank you I you know uh I
know it when I see it puts it into a
subjective realm and we can't dealing
with subjectivity here I understand
where you're coming from on the language
use here thank you thank you for the
question other questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
rep thank you Mr chair I'm next gonna
please
good afternoon thank you Mr chairman and
uh committee
members I um for the record I'm
representative Bill King and I represent
Hillsboro District 43 the town of
Milford um before I start in on my
presentation um I I will say that uh I
think some of the terms that we could
use to define pornography wouldn't
really be very nice to put in a
bill um and I will also say that
um pornography is no longer your average
Playboy
magazine um some of our youth are are
witnessing some pretty violent sexual
acts on on uh on the internet and it's a
cause for concern and I hope this bill
uh gets the attention that it
deserves three and a half years ago I
ran to represent Milford as a state
representative I ran because of my
passion to help those suffering from
addiction originally the desire came
from my relationship with Ark NH in
Milford and substance use
disorder during my first term serving on
Health Human Services and elderly
Affairs committee I learned there was a
lot more to addiction than
Suds at the root of much addiction is
mental
health mental health has now become my
main focus and one Factor driving poor
mental health starts with what our
teenagers and sadly younger are exposed
to on their cell phones and their
computers through the internet
content pornography is one of such
influence our kids are experiencing and
it is easy to
access this bill is an attempt to make
it harder for kids to access porn on
their
devices in June
2023 at the uh DHHS oversight committee
meeting Patricia Tilly and Jennifer o
Higgins presented their report on social
media impact on youth mental
health in their report they mentioned
Children and Youth are exposed to
messages from social media influencers
which I would consider this one hidden
ads in video games data collection
across many platforms such as this
virtually re virtual reality and
encounters with strangers in games and
targeted social media advertisements
that are intended to make children take
action porn sites are just one area that
are impacting our
children the bill is not a new concept
as representative mafit did a very very
good job uh introducing this and um
there's there is a similar version uh
that passed the initial one passed in L
Louisiana in 2022 so these this has not
had a lot of time to to Really grab
traction however he did also mention uh
Utah and Mississippi also Arkansas
Montana Virginia and Texas have passed
similar
bills you may ask does this bill
accomplish what it sets out to do reduce
access to teens in the first year after
Louisana passed this bill porn access
dropped 80% as reported by ethical
capital Capital Partners a private
PornHub representative Lori Schlagel is
the Trailblazer from Louisiana that was
able to spear had a similar this uh a
similar Bill to this through their
legislative
branch if you think this may have been
promoted by Evangelical Christians think
again this bill actually got its start
when representative schel was listening
to the Howard Stern Show and pop star
Billy ellish told his story about
watching porn at age 11 and how it
destroyed his brain and how he felt
incredibly devastated that he was
exposed to so much
porn we need to think about our
children's mental health and I hope you
vote
OTP maybe with an amendment but OTP just
the same for this bill and help prevent
what our kids are exposed to online
thank you for your time I'm open to
questions I also did bring the DHHS
report from June if anybody wants to see
this it is my copy so um I would like it
back I'm open to
questions questions for this
Smith
I'm not I'm not really sure how to ask
this
question I am under the
impression that first of all most
electronic devices have on and off
switches and second that
I and I think I am not alone take very
strongly responsibility
to I mean I took it to my children I see
my children take that responsibility to
my
grandchildren of making
sure that there are limits that have
been
established according to that
family's
values I don't really see
how this is going to help and I must be
missing something I understand that so
help me help me understand what I'm
missing so I'm I'm not a computer
science expert but I will let you know
and the entire committee as as well
there is a huge education that we as
adults need to learn about the
technology that is is in the hands of
our kids there are way ways around
things that the parents think they've
set up and you're
wrong there are ways of logging in under
one and making it look like your parents
have control on your
device and then as soon as the parents
are out of sight they log in under
something else and there's a totally
different access that they
have the uh the power that these kids
have with their cell phones and the
internet access that they have is
tremendous and we cannot UND
underestimate
that representative Alexander thank you
Mr chair just to follow up on that if
what you say is true what is this going
to
do we're a bunch of adults trying to
regulate what children do and you're
saying that they're smarter than what we
think I mean I'm 29 I think I know my
way around a smartphone but maybe an
18-year-old knows more 17 15y old I'm
not sure there's an old saying that if
you can't figure out your cell phone
find a
14-year-old um uh but seriously what
this bill does is it doesn't control
what's going on on on this side of the
cell phone it's controlling what's
happening on the other side of the cell
phone and so um they can't they can't
allow access unless they prove that
older
sorry about that sorry no problem right
um other question yes representative
Stapleton well this is a difficult one
because 10 plus years ago um first
episode was
sexting and then even then the kids were
far ahead of us because they would had
images and they took images of
themselves or their associate students
and sent them all over and to one
another and hideous
stuff um and you know we were blind to
it and I only found out about it when my
8-year-old
grandson um had pictures on his cell
phone that were in appropriate and we
corrected that right away but they are
so far ahead of us we do need to have
some guard rails and stop measures um
otherwise it's just going to get worse
as you point out in your fine testimony
here thank you thank you other
questions so represent I wonder if I
could just uh follow up on a question
that representative Alexander asked
earlier it it's my understanding that
let's use the PornHub as the example
it's my understanding is that what this
bill is intended to do is
to stop
PornHub from
Distributing uh uh pornographic material
to miners by requiring them to
get appropriate verification that the
person's over uh 18 years old that is
not clear on is
if to use to go back to his example if
if I own a small restaurant that has
internet
service and I and I you know I obviously
know that something called pornhub or or
like things exist on the
internet
um and I and I am aware that
PornHub
can you know that somebody that somebody
that uh uh has access to the internet
can get on to uh to pornhub by doing
that am
I am I is the intent of this to make me
liable if I don't do something to make
sure that the kids that come into my
restaurant are not you know accessing
PornHub that is not the intent of the
bill it the intent is to put the
responsibility on PornHub or uh site
similar to that I will also say that uh
in my days working in
corporate um porn was something that
would show up on people's computers and
the IT people would go in Block sites so
if that's something um that you know if
the day comes and restaurants are
worried about or whoever is offering
internet service they can have somebody
come in and block sites or they can
block the sites themselves right but I
mean just just because I think the
question the point he was getting at
that I would be also worried about is
it's it's not the intent of this bill
and maybe we need to make adjust the
language a little bit but it's not the
intent of this bill to impose upon the
restaurant in my example the obligation
to to uh police the internet in other
words they're not required
to arrange their internet service so
that PornHub is blocked that's correct
okay all right uh yes representative
Smith if you're right and it probably
are that these young people who you're
talking about are much more Adept than
we
are what
is what is to prevent them these unnamed
young
people from beating the system uh
perhaps you know filling out whatever
form has to be filled out to claim that
they are over 18 and that it's all right
to subject them to this
um you know where does
that protection come and I will tell you
that I mean maybe I shouldn't say this
publicly but I will I have had one
occasion in all my years to have a
fleeting glimp Glimpse at something that
would be called
pornography and it was on a
state
computer in room
100 of the um of the state housee I
froze I was
shocked um and immediately went to we
didn't have an IT office then but went
to the appropriate people who who
blocked it yeah um but
so I'm not speaking as an expert here
but you're saying the kids are experts
and that they do know how to beat the
system so why wouldn't they beat this
system I guess there's no guarantees at
all in life but I like the when
representative Mafia used the word guard
rails and actually representative
Alexander repeated that uh I I would say
it's it's you know how how can we
actually guarantee that everybody will
drive 65 and under when the speed limit
is
65 um
there I don't think there's any
guarantee but I think what this law will
do will will it will significantly cut
down on uh just your average youth that
sites other questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
sir thank you I'm next going to call on
please thank you and thank you for
giving me the opportunity to um to speak
to this bill I I just want to start by
saying I I really appreciate rep Moffett
and all the other bipartisan group of
co-sponsors who've joined together to
advocate for youth health and for uh
youth health and Youth Development it's
very very much
appreciated um I'll start reading some
of the testimony I have but but based
off some of the comments I'm glad that
I'm here because I can speak to the
parental issue and um also we're the
purpose of this bill really is to add in
a layer of age
verification onto sites that this is
their business to have elicit material
so that we can ensure ensure that the
people that are viewing this illicit
material aren't under the legal age of
adulthood that's the intent and in
discussing some of the like the State
House website and this in the bill it it
actually clearly states that this is
intended for a commercial entity that
knowingly or intentionally publishes and
distributes material um that for which
this is their business so this isn't an
accidental kind of a you know there's
something on some accident site that
comes through the State House
algorithms um I would like to say that
online pornography is incredibly easy
for adolescence to to access due to the
lack of age verification
requirements and the pro proliferation
of personal electronic devices
accessible to Children we've discussed
that and I'm going to highlight some of
the information on this and I'm going to
use PornHub as a reference uh because I
have some data on that but they they are
no means the only the only uh purveyor
of commercial porn that's that this
would apply to um and I already sent
this in as testimony to the committee
there's quite a bit of data in here and
there's it's all cited and all of those
citations are in there if you want to
look at it later so according to the
data reported in Psychology today well
over 90 billion videos are viewed daily
on PornHub it's the world largest
pornography website and more than 65 has
more than 64 million view uh visitors
74% that are male 26% female according
to a May 2023 report published by uh
Britain's children's commissioner almost
2third of young adults uh reported that
they have intentionally or accidentally
viewed porn this is likely to be an
underestimation given the embarrassing
nature of the self-report type of data
the average age in which children
intentionally or accidentally view uh
pornography is 13 with incidents much
much lower almost half of boys who had
reported uh intentionally in viewing it
they also report viewing it frequently
uh once CE or twice once or twice or
more per week a fifth of boys who had
intentionally viewed porn every day more
often um a fifth of boys had
intentionally viewed porn every day uh
that's one of the natures of pornography
is just like many other things it's it's
addictive it's an addictive uh issue for
adults it's an addictive issue
particularly for children who don't have
developed senses of addiction
control and the majority of pornography
is viewed online because it's easy
ramifications of this are children learn
social norms by their personal
experiences and what they View and uh
pornography viewing increases their
perceptions of inaccurate sexual scripts
which include sexual exploitation of
others sexual violence and even rape a
British study revealed that many young
people Express an expectation now that
sex involves physical
aggression 16 to 20 one year olds uh
surveyed reported that um the survey
found that young people who are
frequently exposed to pornography were
significantly more likely to have been
involved in a physically aggressive or
degrading SE sex act either as the child
who had been harmed or the person who
did the
harm pornography is absent of any
emotional context that forms healthy
adult relationships and many who view
pornography have feelings of guilt and
shame which further adds to the mental
health exasperation of young people now
this is besides the emotional and
developmental growth of children one of
the things to keep in mind um
underscoring all of this is there are
additional concerns with the operational
model of some of these uh major porn
sites many online pornography sites are
built on video sharing models where
independent developers can upload their
content onto the site this is an issue
because the hosting company cannot
ensure that this is free from Child
exploitation and human trafficking and
this has actually been quite the issue
lately I don't know if this is called
Alo or ILO a yo Holdings it's a company
formerly called mindgeek it's the parent
company of PornHub a 2020 study found
that nearly half of pornhub's content
contains sexual violence and women were
the target of this violence 97% of the
time uh interestingly in January 2020 a
US judge awarded damages to a group of
women who the court had found had been
coed and tricked into making pornography
um by the uh by a video sharing site
hosted on PornHub in April of 2021 a
congressional briefing was held to
discuss mindgeek who had been
scrutinized for hosting videos of child
sexual abuse rape and trafficking in
June of 2021 a lawsuit was filed against
mindgeek electing alleging that PornHub
and mindgeek knowingly profited from
videos depicting rape child sexual
exploitation revenge porn human
trafficking and other non-consensual
consensual sexual content in December of
2023 just last month Alo Holdings was
arraigned in a New York federal court on
charges of engaging in unlawful monetary
transactions involving sex trafficking
proceeds proceeds for pornhub's role in
hosting videos and accepting payments
from Criminal actors who coerced young
women into engaging sexual acts on
videos that were posted without their
content or their consent on a personal
note I'm the mother of four children I
have two uh two daughters and two sons
I will let you know that as a parent it
is almost impossible to raise your child
in a pornified society in a porn
accessible Society no matter what you do
as a parent you are not going to be able
to to you're not going to be able to put
controls on the situation where you
actually can um limit this for your
children it's very difficult no matter
how many password protections algorithms
on our child children's devices who are
now young adults and my youngest is in
high school um we've always had the
controls to their phones we've always
had those things still impossible
um there's just it's it just cannot be
it cannot be overstated how much parents
even who try to do the right thing are
having difficulty and I'll be honest
with you our state laws are not helping
parents we're actually we make this
harder on
parents um and it is honestly it's a
it's a personal tra it's a real Travy
tra sorry tragedy what an uphill parent
what uphill battles parents have to go
through right now now will this
completely limit young people from
having access to porn no no it won't
however it is it is something we have to
do something it is a it is a starting
speed bump to address the fact that you
have human sexual
material trafficking material child rape
material you have all of this worse it's
this is fully accessible to adults which
is worse enough all we're trying to do
here is we're trying to put some a stop
Gap measure to see if we can actually
keep that from being accessible to
children and as we've seen in the
results in Louisiana there is there is
some benefit to
this um I would like to to say that one
thing that this bill does it's it's just
a way to be proactive and start I ating
the harms uh to Youth Development and
really to combat sexual violence overall
if that's something that people in this
committee you know I know you're all
committed everyone here is committed to
public health and safety and I know a
lot of everyone here is committed to
combating sexual
violence some interesting facts some
other states and uh countries that have
en enacted this age verification
interestingly what I found out when I
started researching it it has huge
bipartisan support and uh these laws
have passed in a number of states to
include Louisiana Texas Virginia
Arkansas Mississippi and Montana in this
year alone there there are 16 age
verification bills in introduced across
the US in the states who have passed
these laws like I said it's typically
typically bipartisan in Louisiana it
passed 100 to zero with 30 Dems 68
Republicans and two Independence in
Texas it passed 135 to 5 with five de uh
57 democ rats and 78 Republicans in
Virginia it passed 39 to zero with 21
Democrats and 18 Republicans
interestingly just last month December
2023 the European Union a block of 27
Nations began requiring age verification
for online porn pornography sites with
penalty violations up to 6% of the
company's Global revenues I'm not
suggesting that but I'm just letting you
know what the EU is doing this is a
worldwide conversation and it's you know
for lack of federal movement on this
it's up to us in the states to act does
anyone have any questions for me I'm
happy to take any questions for this
witness yes representative Alexander
thank you and I'm sorry for so many
questions I guess I'm just confused at
what this would actually actually do
because I'm I'm on the liquor New
Hampshire state liquor store website and
when I log in it says You must be of
legal age to enter this site are you
over 21 yes or no that's all you have to
say so if a minor wanted to go on
PornHub all PornHub would have to do is
say are you over the age of 18 yes or no
no that's not what this bill says okay
this bill because in this bill in the
language of the bill it and it R moff
you can correct me if I'm wrong but in
the language of this bill it is a an
uploading of a an ID card and it says in
this bill that the the third party that
is in charge of this security feature is
not allowed to retain that ID but that's
a partion of that I'll try to find
exactly where it is but you know on the
Fly I don't think I'm going to get to it
it's on it's on uh page two uh ran
numeral 8 I
think okay so a user would have to
upload a state issued driver's license
or or access that website uh it would be
whatever the the type of ID I think it
just says governmen issued ID okay yeah
and that's one there and um yes all
right other questions for this yes
representative D Lorenzo thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question you know I'm looking at this
bill and listening to you speak and um
I'm getting a little bit confused um you
know kids being um curious about
sexuality and sex um is normal it's a
normal right of passage um I know when I
was growing up you know Brothers kids in
the neighborhood would um look for their
parents um Playboy magazines under the
mattress or huster and all that stuff so
it's sort of like a write of Passage and
what I'm hearing from when you speak
what I'm what I'm hearing from you is
that
um a child who's exposed to um
pornography or whatever we think of his
pornography is subject to become
dependent on it um it's almost like I'm
thinking just because your kid looks at
porn it doesn't mean that they're going
to grow up into being Ted Bundy and
that's the sort of panic that I'm that
I'm hearing and feeling here um sure do
you want me to answer to that well yeah
sure okay so you know and and perhaps
there's there's a plenty of data out
there that you can look at you can
easily you can easily uh look up some of
these things but the unfortunately the
really addictive nature of pornography
is it's you know it and this is I'll
honest with this is the talk I gave to
my boys it starts off by looking at cute
cheerleaders online and and then it gets
a little graphic and then looking at
cute cheerleaders isn't enough now you
got to look at naked cute cheerleaders
and then all of a sudden that becomes
not enough because every at every level
you get desensitized to what you're
seeing and the only re and then you have
to go and seek out harder and harder
corn uh por uh porn uh images video
whatever there's there's a negative
progression that happens regularly and
the problem that we have is that sure
maybe you know 1980 where all you have
to choose from is is Playboy there is a
deep deep dark hole of really awful
content and that is propagated online to
be honest with you and another thing
that is also very concerning is that
it's very widely understood that
pornography exposure is used as a
deliberate strategy to groom children
because it constantly desensitizes them
to aberant sexual content so we have
taken something that human sexuality and
we have inverted it to a a point where
it's we are this the stuff that children
can see the honestly the stuff that
adults can see it's it's really just
beyond that what everyone could have
even imagined from 1980 to now does that
answer your question or does that answer
you're did you did I touch upon the
thing that you wanted to that you had
made a statement about no not at all and
I'm thinking of State of Mind of the
person who's U you know like addicted to
pornography
um I would kind of think that they're
probably not normal um and I don't think
you can turn I don't think you can turn
a normal kid into an a normal kid
because they've they've um seen
pornography so there has to be some sort
of a mental lapse there or mental issue
there I think well what you and I are
doing right now is having a conversation
we're not really I mean I'm I'm showing
you right here PornHub has 64 million
views viewers so you know don't take my
word for it go look at go look at the
net profit of porn across in the us
alone the net profit of porn is
astronomical so if if there is not a a
addictive nature that there's plenty of
people that are I would guess viewing
porn that you would have no idea um it's
highly it's a high big business to be
honest with you
so lot of repeat
customers yes representative G thank you
Mr chair and thank you uh for your
testimony do you have any statistics
within your information about the number
of convicted child molesters and or
rapists and or other sexual
predators uh
who became addicted to pornography where
or where the use of pornography was
prevalent in their lives prior to their
Commission of a sexual crime I don't
have any specific uh stats on that um
like I had just touched upon you
know pornography exposure obviously is
is often used as deliberate strategy to
groom children and and that is that is
obviously a big concern but as far as
that goes I don't but there's quite a
bit of data out there on mindgeek and
the legal troubles that they have had
and I I don't know if that's why they
changed their name to Alo Holdings to be
honest with you because they've had a
couple different names but there is
there's a lot of undercover reporting
that's been done on mindgeek where
people from mindgeek themselves have
fully admit that they can't keep child
child rape human trafficking sexual
violence and other things that are
highly illegal off their site um so that
doesn't necessarily answer what you had
but but there is a a huge legal
component to what's going on with
mindgeek for the last four to five
years other questions for this witness
so you know I want to just follow up as
I'm sort of thinking about this um
follow up on a question I asked of Prior
witness so um the representative King I
believe said that he was that was not
the intent of the bill in the in
representative
Alexander's uh example of the you know
the mom restaurant was not the it was
not the uh uh purpose of this bill to
capture the restaurant or put some
burden on the restaurant to police what
you know if they have Wi-Fi access what
goes on in the Wi-Fi access my NE my my
next question though is what
about suppose I'm I'm I
run uh an internet service in other
words suppose I'm Microsoft or or
Facebook or whatever I maybe Facebook's
a bad but suppose I'm Microsoft and I
provide internet service you know all
over the place for around the world um
and one of the one of the people that uh
one of the businesses that uses my
Microsoft Internet service is
PornHub so is it the purpose of does
this bill capture Microsoft in my
example or is it only or is it only
PornHub as I read the bill yeah it is it
refers specifically the intent is about
commercial entities that are Publishers
of porn that's their business
Microsoft's business isn't porn but a
porn company's business is porn so well
except that I mean under the under the
law could would they be considered to be
because because Microsoft passes
on the the
uh you know what PornHub Microsoft
passes on to me for example if if I if I
have a computer and I plug into PornHub
Microsoft passes on to me from PornHub
what's on on PornHub so in some sense
they could be considered a publisher
could they not well I mean these these
technicalities can be ironed out in
language and legislation which I'm I'm
sure you all are very capable of doing
and so some of these I'll call it the
restaurant dilemma where we could we
could sort of we talk about the sort of
the well what if this and these are all
good things but that that can be kind of
dealt with within legislation okay so no
no no I I don't disagree I guess what I
want to make sure is your intent is not
to capture Microsoft in my example the
intent of this bill is as it's written
by by uh Rhett Moffet and uh the
co-sponsors is that any commercial
entity that knowingly or intentionally
publishes or distributes uh material
potentially harmful Myers on the
internet from a website that contains a
substantial portion of such material
shall be head Li shall be held liable so
it's it's it's saying here from sites to
which that is their that's their ma
majority portion of their content okay
so you all right so you would say that
in in the example you would say
Microsoft is off the hook here because
Microsoft it's not a third of their of
their activity is not is not pornh hubs
well that's not the their substantial
amount of their business that's not
their purpose of their business just
like the libraries off the hook the
restaurants off the hook the coffee
shops off the hook the state house um
lobbies off the hook okay you know that
kind of a thing that offers that and I
will say one thing is really interesting
is when I was looking at this um and
looking at what are some of the you know
what are some of the resist resistance
to legislation like this and it you know
when when you look at some of the cases
that have come up
because because the Texas laws challenge
things like that it always comes down to
First Amendment you know it it never
comes down to well it's the you know
they're trying
to unintentionally in snare a an
internet provider you know or something
like that so the even in other states
that argument really isn't even being
made by people who are actively pushing
back against this legislation and by
people I mean PornHub okay all right
other questions for this
witness seeing none thank you thank you
sir uh Alysa uh Dandrea and Emily
preventure
please
afternoon hi hi good afternoon Mr chair
and members of the committee my name is
Alyssa Dandrea and I'm the community
relations specialist at the New
Hampshire Coalition against Domestic and
Sexual Violence the Coalition is the
umbrella Organization for the state's 12
community- based crisis centers and we
serve more than more than 14,000 adult
and child victims of Domestic and Sexual
Violence every year today I am joined by
my colleague Emily preventure together
we are here to testify in support of hb1
1256 an important Child Protection
measure that will limit youth access to
pornographic and other harmful sexually
explicit material in New
Hampshire good afternoon my name is
Emily preventure and I'm the prevention
specialist at the Coalition this
legislation is aligned with our
Statewide violence prevention efforts
unfortunately the impact of pornography
on New Hampshire youth has become a
significant challenge in our
community-based sexual violence
prevention and healthy relationship
education schools throughout the state
have requested prevention programming in
response to concerning and harmful
Behavior they've seen as a result of
students viewing pornographic material
online to be clear today's pornography
normalizes sexual violence when teens
view pornography they often struggle to
differentiate what they're viewing from
reality and it is formative in creating
ideas of sex and relationships that
directly contradict what we teach about
healthy relationships and consent as
part of our sexual violence prevention
initiatives our work is informed on
healthy stages of childhood development
we know that the prefrontal cortex plays
a key role in regulating thoughts
actions and
emotions for minors this part of the
brain is not yet fully developed and
that can create challenges in their
ability to conceptualize the fact that
in most pornographic videos the consent
is only being given off
camera it's an unfortunate reality that
many teens in the granite state are
looking to pornography as a way to learn
about sex which is giving them all the
wrong answers about healthy
relationships and consent in the 2021
youth risk behavior survey 11% of
students reported experiencing sexual
violence this mirrors is what we know
about the reality of sexual assault in
New Hampshire
we can only expect this number to
decrease if we ensure that students
receive age appropriate and
trauma-informed information about
healthy relationships the messages youth
get from pornography contradict what we
are focused on in our sexual violence
prevention programming House Bill 1256
will create important safeguards to
block minors from accessing pornography
online while this bill will not
eliminate sexual violence in our state
it is a step in the right direction to
prevent miners from being exposed to
harmful content
we hope you consider supporting this
legislation today and we thank you for
helping protect New Hampshire children
we'd be happy to answer any questions
questions for this witness or these
Witnesses I'm
sorry seeing none thank you very much
next I'm going to call on J pinet please
from the American civil liberties
Union
sorry
uh thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee jel biset I'm the legal
director of the ACLU of New Hampshire um
this is a bill that we have First
Amendment concerns with um I can just
tell you that um as was mentioned before
there have been seven states that have
enacted similar laws Arkansas Montana
Mississippi Louisiana Utah Virginia and
Texas these are pretty new laws um that
have started kind of coming into place
um over the the past couple years and
there have been uh three pieces of
litigation um um arising out of Texas
Louisiana and Utah my understanding is
the Louisiana and Utah cases uh were uh
dismissed on the basis that there was an
inability of the plaintiffs to bring a
pre-enforcement challenge so I I don't
I'm not uh I don't understand those
decisions to have addressed the First
Amendment implications um of these types
of laws the Texas law uh there was a
preliminary injunction issued on First
Amendment grounds that injunction was
ultimately uh stayed by by the fifth
circuit but that Texas decision um is I
think the
um most recent kind of indication that
we have at least where one Court um has
gone in in evaluating the
constitutionality so you know this is a
really kind of new type of legislation
and the courts are still processing it
um I can articulate some of those first
amendment concerns but I think my
general kind of feedback is it really
just may make sense to wait to see how
those uh pieces of litigation get
handled by the district courts and then
ultimately by the circuit courts um
because there are legitimate First
Amendment issues that I just want to
walk the committee through and I think
just the under the overarching principle
um that I just want to kind of make
clear is that non-obscene adult content
is First Amendment protected speech and
even if it is harmful to Miners and
meets the standard as to miners right
which is articulated in the Ginsburg
case it still is can be protected as to
adults so I just want to be kind of very
clear about that that this can
ultimately impact um Pro protected
content under the First Amendment as to
adults because the bread of this law
would impact adults and I think that
underlies the First Amendment concerns
that we and other organizations have
raised and ultimately the concerns that
that Texas Court um evaluated and um
that that Texas decision is is on
footnote one um of our um our written
testimony and so how does this
ultimately impact adults because I think
that is where the key First Amendment
issue lies uh in our view this would
burden uh uh Speech rights of all users
who seek to access regulated sites and
it would uh ultimately deprive them of
anonymity um and in chill privacy and
security-minded people from accessing
sites that they have a constitutional
right to access right as adults and so
if allowed to go into effect our view is
that this bill will require all internet
users including adults to provide
personal information right that section
eight that was mentioned before you have
to present you know a government issued
ID potentially or a a digital ID that's
like a real thing right a real real
burden you present that online a company
now has access to that I understand that
there are parameters in this bill to try
to you know deter misuse of that
information but it is still a burden and
a hurdle that will undoubtedly chill
some people from engaging in their
constitutionally protected rights here
um I know that there was some testimony
before about Louisiana and how after
Louisiana enacted their law there's been
an 80% increase I would submit that that
probably is evidence of chill right
because I don't think I I'm very
skeptical that it's 80% of individuals
in Louisiana who are all minors right
who now don't have access I think that
what that probably indicates is that a
significant number of those individuals
are adults who just decided to not
access that information you know rightly
or wrongly people have that choice but
the concern that um some Advocates have
raised including the ACLU is that um
that really is evidence of of the chill
at the end of the day with respect to um
some of this these types of laws so I
think ultimately I think the the speech
concerns are real they're they're
articulated in that preliminary
injunction decision in Texas um that we
quote in our written testimony but I
think my recommendation would be to
maybe wait to see how those cases uh
sort themselves out uh but I would
encourage folks to read that decision
because I think it it it it articulates
many of the concerns we have there is a
difference a material difference I do
want to flag between this law and the
Texas law the Texas law also had a
series of disclaimers that were required
with respect to to pornography we don't
we don't have that um but I think the
other portions of the Texas uh decision
um apply with the same Force to the the
bill that's before this committee all
right thank you yes representative test
question so as as I understand it the
ACLU believes that uh child
pornography uh should not be regulated
is that true
I can just tell you the position of the
ACLU is we need to beware of
restrictions that in an over Brad
fashion Encompass protected speech that
is our position and I think that is what
this bill would do at the end of the day
follow up yes so uh do you have a in
your mind some sort of a law that could
be used to pre prevent child pornography
I I don't know I mean I could tell you
when you look at the cases when you go
back to ACLU versus Reno in 1997 one of
the things that that Court talked about
as a more narly tailored or a lesser
restrictive alternative right is just
the um the importance and usage of of
filters right and we now all have that
on our phones is that something that
parents can use on an individualized
basis with their families and I think
what this law does that is a little bit
different and Justice Scalia I think is
kind of talked a little bit about this
um is that this law these types of laws
they don't enforce parental authority
over children's speech they impose
government Authority subject only to a
parental veto and I think that is kind
of the general libertarian concern with
um these types of these types of
statutes yes just one one last question
so from your perspective there really
shouldn't be any limits uh you you can
talk about all these but you basically
have some way to turn around and prevent
or to object to any of these kind of
Liberties well again I I can only just
rearticulate my position and which is I
think consistent where the Texas Court
came out which is that when you have a
regulation that deals with speech rights
which this does including protected
speech rights that adults haven't have a
con tional right to access and consume
you need to be very careful and more
tailored than you need to be in other
areas of the law given the the real
importance of the First Amendment so
that's just why I'm here is to
articulate that there could be some
tailoring concerns here in so far as
this impacts protected speech which is
where you know one District Court kind
of landed at the preliminary injunction
stage other questions for this word yes
representative
grion in order to reset the phone number
on my Robin Hood account they want me to
upload a picture of my government issued
ID in order to do some uh various
different things on on my Facebook
account they wanted me to upload an
image of my governmen issued ID when I
go and well I don't but if if I wanted
to go to the liquor store and get some
alcohol I have to show my governmen
issued ID if I want to check into a
motel I have to provide a government
issued ID I'm 52 years old I'm well over
the age of of of consent for all of
these
things why is it an issue to provide a
some form of government issued ID to
access
pornography the difference here is
you're dealing with a potential
government mandate right uh with respect
to how one can access speech and I think
that is the concern at the end of the
day and where I think this is
distinguisher
from say going to a liquor store and
presenting an ID here is that the fear
and consequences of data misuse from
uploading an ID to a website for the
purpose of engaging and consuming speech
I think is enough to scare away users
from accessing their constitutional
right to uh information and so I think
that is the concern at the end of the
day and I think um some of that is
echoed in the Texas decision uh which I
would encourage the committee to
review other question questions for this
witness so Mr President I I I haven't
read the Texas decision and obviously
something that I will do but um let me
ask you I the the language in section
four of this bill and as again as I say
if you if you assume that that the
requirement to meet the definition is
that it must meet all of the subsections
a b and c not just any one of them but
all of them my understanding is that
that language comes
largely from existing Supreme Court case
law on what is pornography and I
think that that case law would say that
even as to
adults something that meets that
definition could be
prohibited so if that's if that's true
and this doesn't prohibit that as to
adults in other words I guess what I'm
saying is if if it's true that that
definition would allow a state to
prohibit even adults from possessing
such material why and we don't do that
why would it be unconstitutional as to
Children yeah so this language comes
from the Ginsburg decision uh which is
also footnoted and the point that really
I was trying to make here is when you
look at that standard with respect to
minors on line 13 when you look at that
standard um on line 18 with respect to
min
is that there easily could be a set of
information that fits this criteria as
to miners but wouldn't as to adults
which is the Miller test right which
came down several years before so there
is a gap there it is true if um this
said with respect to adults that would
fit the Miller definition of obscenity
which is not protected which can be
regulated the point that I'm just trying
to make here is this would cover
material that's that that is protected
as to a adults that would be on these
websites that individuals would now have
to use their license to access and the
concern that we have given the fact that
that information would be protected
under uh Miller uh um because you could
have something that's prohibited as two
minors but not as adults that that would
provide a chill with respect to access
that information okay well I no I guess
I want to make sure I think I'm a little
bit confused because I'm guess what I'm
saying is I I certainly agree with you
completely that there can be differences
between what is prohibited as to adult
what is prohibited as to children but
is isn't am I incorrect that something
that meets the definition of A and B and
C
is a a state can prohibit that even as
to
adults I'm not sure about that I guess
and that's maybe where there's a
disconnect here is that I I have I've
always kind of thought that there was a
gap
um there right because you can have
something that this would be not
protected with respect to minor access
that's the Ginsburg decision but it
could be uh could be protected under the
First Amendment because it doesn't meet
the same standard as to adults which
would be the Miller test and so that's
where I just kind of see a gap here I
hope that makes I hope that makes sense
I I I I think I understand what you're
saying all right um all right other
question yes representative gon please
thank you
you you mentioned this chilling effect
and I'm
wondering does age
verification where the government has
imposed a an age
restriction provide a chilling effect on
any other activities like say maybe
tattoo you're you're worried about
you're worried about chilling effect
yeah because government might impose an
age restriction is there any chilling
effect on people getting tattoos maybe
which is Free Speech maybe that's I mean
that maybe the same argument could be
made there I mean again I think the
concern that we have at the end of the
day is you have a chilling effect with
respect to First Amendment protected
activity which is um I think the same
analysis where that the Texas Court
landed on in its preliminary injunction
decision yes uh representative Alexander
please thank you um thank you for taking
my question um the recently passed
Constitutional Amendment regarding the
right to privacy nobody's brought that
up today but I guess I'm wondering would
this be a violation in your opinion of
that new Constitutional Amendment
because the government is opposing the
age restriction on license ver
verification not the private company
itself which in the situations
representative gon gave they were
private companies imposing that in this
case we're telling the private company
they must verify the
age it's a good qu I think the answer is
I don't know to be honest well you're
not a constit you're not a Supreme Court
Judge right yeah
um you know the the the right to
informational privacy under the state
constitution is is new um and I don't
think we've really seen uh certainly the
state supreme court evaluate what the
Contour of that um is I my I suspect
that proponents of this bill would say
it probably doesn't violate those
Provisions in part because the language
on page two lines 28 through 29 that
talk about how this information can't be
retained you know for for various uh
purposes um you know we don't think
that's sufficient for various reasons uh
with respect to U the chill that would
that we think would would be created um
but I suspect that PE people could rely
on this language to say it does not
violate that state constitutional
provision yes representative gon you you
bring up an excellent point uh if we
were to include language in this bill
that says anyone uh found in violation
of the new right to privacy uh a company
that retain CH this data would then you
know just reinforcing that that is in
the law that they would be subject to
that uh to to the to that new law if we
put that statement in there if you keep
the data uh or retain the data then you
would be subject to that law we put that
in there is some language in there yeah
I think that language is already in here
and and um as I articulate I just don't
think that that's sufficient there was
similar language in Texas if I'm not
mistaken as
well other questions for this witness
thank you very much
Mr is there anyone else who wishes to be
heard on House Bill 1256 yes did you
give us a card I'm sorry ah okay you if
you if you just give it to
representative trip we'll he'll get it
hi hello Judiciary
Committee my name is is Trisha nalu I'm
representing myself and my community
today I am a certified sex educator and
intimacy coordinator and I have been an
actor and producer of adult
entertainment for 20 years I am also
founder of the erotic laborers Alliance
England I worked recently on a
curriculum called porn Literacy for
Boston
University and the goal for that was for
High School curriculum teaching the
difference between entertainment and
education clearly there's a lack of
comprehensive sexual education in this
country I oppose this bill on behalf of
myself and my community because House
Bill 1256 harms the consumer and the
content creator First Amendment
protections apply to online speech as
much as
offline with a the third party
government regulation on our websites is
not clear if we would be allowing access
to all Communications between content
creator and
consumer that would naturally deter
consumers from trusting that their adult
appetites and or Communications within
the website would be
private in 1996 the US Congress passed a
law section 230 originally part of the
communications decency act that protects
Americans freedom of expression online
by protecting the inter intermediaries
we all rely on Congress wanted to
encourage internet users and services to
create and find communities section 230
text explains how Congress wanted to
protect the internet's unique ability to
True diversity of political decorse
discourse
sorry and opportunities for cultural
development diverse communities have
flourished online providing us with
political educational cultural and yes
entertainment services users meanwhile
have new ways to control the content
that they see it is not currently the
burden of the state to collect and
safely store copies of government
identification for consumers who are
using the
internet age verification legislation
has passed in many states in Louisiana
Mississippi Arkansas and as you heard
Texas it's already resulting in a an out
of work situation for adult content
creators the New Hampshire adults that
are seeking entertainment deserve to
search the vast worldwide web without
having to upload their government issued
identification we can all agree that
underage viewing of adult entertainment
is not something that we want happening
all of
us and to note on earlier comments not
everyone who produces Adult
Entertainment is a groomer
um there are other ways to protect
minors from viewing potentially harmful
adult
material we believe in our community
that parents not government should
restrict what is allowed to be viewed
there is technology that exists to Aid
in the parental responsibility to
control the potential content that their
children may have access
to as I know from an email on the 8th of
January there are new PornHub
regulations there's currently new
regulations with PornHub surrounding
consent and access
to the material on that
site there are also already pay walls in
place for most adult websites not PE not
PornHub there are many nonprofit
organizations at work right now to
mitigate underage viewing of adult
content the Electronic Frontier Freedom
the electronic Freedom Frontier the Free
Speech Coalition are available to offer
reasonable situations and solutions that
do not involve government regulation and
as we can see the
ACLU believes it would be in violation
of the First
Amendment um yeah I have more but I'm
not going to keep going on so thank you
so much for hearing me today and I'm
open to any questions that you might
have all right thank you questions to
this Witness
seeing none thank you very much thank
you so much is there anyone else who
wishes to be heard on House Bill
1256 right seeing none I'm going to
close the hearing on House Bill
1256 and I'm now going to open the
1412 and I will
recognize representative
uh leas who uh is
testify uh in place of uh one one of the
sponsors I should say yes yeah um thanks
to the chair and the committee uh yeah a
brief uh history on how this came to be
there number of bills related to
occupational licensing that the governor
requested um Majority Leader Osborne to
submit he submitted the lsrs but doesn't
didn't have time to deal with them nor
did the chair of house cdna and I got
asked to uh to take care of these and uh
anyway so that's why I'm introducing
this rather than representative
Osborne um basically what this does is
repeal the uh the requirement for court
reporters to be
licensed um what I handed around is the
application uh to get a license a court
reporter and um one of the key
requirements other than paying a $300
fee is uh to show that you and provide
details that you've been certified by
either the national court reporters
Association or the national verbatim
reporters Association which are you know
private um certification and you know uh
professional
organizations
and you know any of the other
requirements that are on here are thing
you know those and any other
requirements on here are things that an
employer of a court reporter could
certainly um ask for and some of them
are you know similar to other things
that are asked of uh people applying for
a
position um there's someone here from
oplc that can give uh details on their
experience with the court reporters but
basically there's relatively few of them
that are
licensed and um for the last quite a few
years there have been um zero
disciplinary issues the boards basically
had nothing to do and um and I I don't
believe I don't believe that uh there's
a a need for this license to exist
anymore um I can answer questions but um
they might be better directed to uh the
person here from oplc but I'll do what I
can all right thank you questions for
this
witness seeing none thank you very much
thank you next I'm going to call on
when I started out in the house 20 years
ago in 2004 Mr chairman this is my first
committee so it's nice coming home again
for the record my name is Steve schliff
I represent mamac district 15 which is W
want to conquer the village of Penacook
and I I'm here today to speak in
opposition to this bill on January 1st
of 2000 I retired after 26 years with
the US Department of Justice United
States Marshall Services a supervisory
Deputy US Marshall and I spent a lot of
time in federal courts all across the
country but primarily here in New
Hampshire and I can still hear the words
of the late chief judge of the US
District Court for New Hampshire judge
Shane Devine telling an attorney who was
speaking so fast that you were s they
were getting paid by the word to slow
down and as judge Divine would tell
councel councel of the most important
person in this courtroom isn't me the
trial judge it's our court reporter
who's making a complete record of every
word that's being said in this courtroom
today Mickey Spain was an author of the
popular uh Mike Hammer detective
novels and he once got a h copy of one
of his latest book back from the
publisher and he realized the publisher
left out six words so he called his uh
editor of Simon and Schuster and said
you took six words out of my book why he
said Mickey you don't understand in
publishing these books by having one
full page we could take out of the book
by not having those words there and when
you're printing thousands of books
you're saving a lot of money by not
having one page eliminated so that's a
good thing and he says Mickey here at
Simon and Schuster our average novel is
70,000 Pages do you think anybody's
going to miss six
words so in his next manuscript he sent
to Simon and Schuster the editor was
reading it proof reading it got to the
end and I can't remember the exact words
but it was something to the effect that
at that point my camera realized that
only one person could have committed
this murder and that person was and he
left it blank
and he got a call from his aditor and he
said Mickey what are you doing who who
was the murder you didn't put in your
transcript he said you told me that six
words weren't important now you know
that one word can be important for a
defendant going through the court system
in here in the granted state if you're
appealing a conviction regardless of the
grounds it's nice to know that the
certified court reporters in this state
realize
like Mickey Spain every single word that
is said is important and it could be
important to a defendant trying to get
an appeal after a conviction and with
that I'll conclude Mr chairman any
questions I'd be glad to answer them
questions for this
witness yes representative
that um represent resentative is I'm
interested in knowing whether there's
any issue um with court reporters about
for
example confidential
information to which they are privy by
nature of of what they're doing and what
system we have we would have if they
were not to be licensed um to guarantee
the protection of all parties involved
in a Judicial matter well I think that's
a a genuinely an important question uh
as was mentioned earlier the court
reporters and members of the national
Court we Porters
Association um and there was mentioned
that's a private organization but so is
the American buyer Association and the
New Hampshire buyer
Association um they
regulate who is a member of that
organization and there's criteria
there's different levels they can
achieve uh in the reporting they do and
um one thing I never saw in my 26 years
in the federal court no one ever
ever had any questions about a
transcript or anything that came out of
a court reporter because they knew it
was going to be a quality product and it
was going to be exact ly what should be
presented most importantly to appeals
court or even up to the US Supreme Court
without that licens to procedure The
Village Idiot could say they're a court
reporter and then we'd pay the
consequences but I'm not going to be a
court reporter so I got to eliminate The
Village Idiot
um that's not true and you know it
um I see you just made me lose my next
question well that was my
purpose
I've lost it so last two of us
yeah any other questions for this
witness thank you very much thank you Mr
chairman thank you committee uh next I'm
please good afternoon my name is Douglas
hHow I am general counsel for the oplc
um my testimon is going to be very brief
but I just wanted to provide a couple of
numbers the kind of things we're seeing
for court reporters
um the office doesn't take a position on
it uh I just want to sort of like I said
give you the numbers currently there are
63 shorthand court reporters licensed uh
in New Hampshire and one voice court
reporter uh there were there have been
zero enforcement matters over the past
five years and then as has been pointed
out there is in order to obtain lure
there is a national certification that
is required um I am happy to take any
questions questions for yes
representative Gree thank you Mr chair
thank you sir for for your
testimony are there any other
professions in the state of New
Hampshire that are not required to get a
license through
oplc but are required to get a licensure
from some private National Organization
or
such that's not a question I think I can
answer I don't know how many professions
that are outside of the open PLC require
certification that don't fall under our
purview other questions for this WT can
I ask you oh I'm sorry represent stapon
go ahead so are you supporting or
opposing this we don't take a position
on this bill okay thank you other
questions so can I ask you sir um I I
representative sherli was here I think
he uh he was as he indicated he was
mostly U aware based on his uh service
in the federal system
am I understanding correctly that
for at least since the early
2000s the state court system does not
make use of court reporters
in regular Court proceedings we now have
court monitors um who are who basically
they they I don't mean to oversimplify
but they they push the record button um
and when this when the hearing starts
and they stop it when they're when the
hearing is over or and maybe stop it in
between but they're not and they are not
licensed is that
correct I'm not aware that there's a
license I I haven't been in a courtroom
in two years um prior to that I did
litigate and I don't think I was ever in
a room with a court reporter but there
may be people here who can speak to that
better than I can but it was in my
experience recorded record right and so
I I will be Happ I certainly will ask
questions of other people who may
testify but my understanding is and
again correct me if you have different
information
that traditional court reporters that
are subject to lure under this are
really only used
now basically
for depositions and things other words
they don't appear they're not there in
court because the court has its own
Court monitors who
um who are not court
reporters in my experience I haven't
seen a court reporter but I can't speak
as to what the licensed individuals are
doing currently so right yeah other
questions for this witness thank you um
Sweeney can you turn on that I'm sorry
can turn on sorry hi I'm Katherine
Sweeney president of the New Hampshire
court reporters Association and um
licensed court reporter 166 I'm one of
the more recent ones I'm in here in
opposition of
1412 I am not just representing myself
I'm representing um all of the lcrs the
licensed court reporters in this state
but more importantly I'm representing
the litigants the actual citizens who
bring cases um in the court not all
court cases are filed by big
corporations with fat wallets they're
brought by Regular People they might
have a property dispute with their
neighbor they might have gruesome
injuries from a car accident they might
have grievances against a medical
provider they might be seeking a divorce
and are worried about the care and
custody of their children a lot of my 32
years has dealt with divorce and I take
a lot of personal information I hope
this addresses your concerns
representative Smith um their
information should remain private and
Protected Their pii their personal
personally identifiable information the
majority of work is uh in divorce during
a deposition I will hear about children
I know their names ages where they go to
school I find out who their doctors and
therapists are what their
extracurricular activities are um their
day-to-day schedule if that gets into an
unlicensed unregulated person's hands I
I shutter to think what could what could
happen I'll also hear about the husband
and wife I know everything that they do
I know their jobs their incomes um their
assets and liabilities I know with their
mortgages um I Mark bank statements
years worth of bank statements and tax
returns that have account information
and so Security numbers I protect that
information and since it's divorce I
will also hear all of the dirty little
secrets I take depositions some real
world examples that I have personally
done is
a husband is asked where the safe is in
his home and how and what's in it and
he'll tell the opposing Council where
the safe is and that there's in this
example
$247,000 worth of gold in another
example a husband at a at a executive
position in a high very popular
financial institution misappropriated
$400,000 of marital funds at a local
gentleman's club for various Services a
wife would take tennis lessons and learn
nothing from the instructor we'll learn
tennis my point being if that
information gets out someone could get
robbed someone could lose their job
someone's reputation is
ruined and my point is in order to
maintain my relationer I am ethically
bound to keep that information private
and secure and safe I take continuing
education credits I'm required to and
that the courses involved technical
techical advancements in my field data
encryption cyber security ethical
obligations and duties that I have
taking away a licensure means that just
just what was said anybody can come in
put a tape recorder on the table record
the proceedings at a deposition and send
that recording out to to gosh knows
where to be transcribed by who where is
the chain of custody who has that
recording and more importantly who is
making sure that nobody is manipulating
that recording in these days of a AI the
artificial intelligence um they're be
they're being touted as a replacement
for court reporters I'm not worried
about my job I am seriously worried
about the litigants and what's going to
happen to their
information if there's no regulation No
Authority no recourse with other
methodology in capturing the record and
no one to complain to when a problem
arises with using inferior technology
what is the public supposed to do
there's no one those recordings could
easily be manipulated it's it's easy
even today to change a yes to a no in an
audio or video recording to fake
someone's what someone has said what's
going to happen tomorrow when an actual
when you can't decipher what an actual
recording is compared to a manipulated
copy that's coming the licens court
reporter in a proceeding outside of a
courtroom where those recordings that
are in court are overseen by a judge
they are done by a court monitor but a
judge is there where are the officers of
the Court where are the licensed court
reporters in the actual depositions
protecting The public's information
thank you questions for this witness
representative tur could you just
Briefly summarize what the Privileges
that come with being a court reporter
are and how sort of the lers
operationalized in terms of your access
does that question in terms of access to
to the court proceedings or whatever
whatever sensitive matters you'd be and
mainly what what was discussed I
apologize for cutting you off there um
mainly what was discussed is we work in
the depos we work in law offices we work
at depositions we don't do Court workor
unless we're paid privately to come in
by attorneys not the state we're not
employed by the state we are all
independent contractors we're not
employed by anyone so no employer is
going to come and vet us for anything
we're we're Bound by our lure that
oversees the state rules yes our
national license our national
certifications just prove that we can
write at this speed and without accuracy
and we take tests written knowledge
tests but we have to follow each State's
rules I can't just move to Illinois
because I have an rpr I have to get
their state certification that's just an
example I'm not sure if Chicago actually
has that sorry so so just a quick
followup for me um so so when entering
these kind of proceedings that you're
talking about your certification is is
sort of examined by somebody currently
yes every deposition that I open it has
my license number on it I state that I'm
a licensed court reporter I have it on
my certificate page that I'm a licensed
court reporter and am happy to answer
any other questions that attorneys may
have at a
deposition about my qualifications
representative
Kat thank you Mr chairman I have two
questions if I
may um
first if you're already certified by the
national court reporters associ
and this isn't really asking any
additional
questions on here at all um what
difference does it make between just
having that like why couldn't you just
give that to the people that are doing
the deposition that hey I have this this
is making you pay an extra $300 for the
application what value is that adding to
you we're happy to pay $300 thank you
kind um but we have um the rsa's Megan
hefler who is our legislative leaon um
do you want to speak to this and the
rules we have to follow we'll hear from
her just second so I'll defer the
question to Megan okay one other
question if I may of course um so had
asked so you're only being used
privately right now you're not being
used in the court so you're
not accessing like say a a closed case
that might be like a guardianship case
that's you know a red confidential case
you're accessing you're providing
services for other things that like a
divorce proceeding isn't typically a
confidential case so if those things
were submitted into court they are
public information somebody could get
them I understand why you're saying some
people may not want that stuff disclosed
but it's not typically like a private
case you're not getting access into
cases that are statutorily sealed is
what I'm really trying to ask sure yes
and I appreciate that but depositions
are not admitted into trials the
testimony is admitted into trials
depositions are just fact finding
missions credibility um finders and
stuff so everything that's testified to
it a deposition is not going to be um
testified to a
trial thank you so question I I mean
that that's not exactly true right I
mean depositions are often used at trial
to cross-examine Witnesses and uh used
to impeach testimony you are correct um
and sometime even even more than that
depending on the circumstances they may
come in if a witness isn't available or
something
um the
the so I you know the I I guess the
thing I have real trouble with is all of
the things that you say are so important
that it that somebody be licensed for uh
because of all the
dangers
um all
of this is sort of the periphery the
stuff that you're doing is sort of the
periphery but when it actually gets to
court and we have to worry about making
sure that the court gets it right and
that there's no that there's no uh
errors in in what people testify about
or that things that are supposed to be
sealed in court are sealed and the ones
that that stuff that's not supposed to
be sealed is not supposed to be sealed
all that is done by a
non-licensed court monitor uh and yet
the court system seems to have been
doing that now for pretty close to 20
years maybe more than 20 years uh and
seems to be operating just fine um so I
you know I I have to say I'm I'm a
little bit skeptical that uh that lure
is uh is such a critical thing for court
reporters and and Court monitors like I
said are monitored by the actual judge
in the courtroom and the state has um
government um contract with transcribers
so they have oversight over the
transcriptions of those Court
recordings by done by the court monitor
so if if somebody has a case in trial
and they want to get a transcript for
appeal um they'd have to go through the
state contracted vendor to get a
transcription so there's oversight even
on that side what I was talking about
and what my job is if if I'm not
licensed and somebody comes into a
deposition who's not licensed they're
not held to any standards any ethical
standards at all any procedural
standards at all and I am
and and why would you not be able to be
held to standards by the the lawyers
that hired you why I mean is it if if we
if if your if court reporters weren't
licensed um is it is it really fair to
think that that the lawyers who employ
who employ people to take records like
you or maybe people who are who are just
recording it uh How likely is it that
you know that if if you are not doing a
good job and you were getting things
wrong that the lawyers that you'd be
long long employed in that in that
occupation whether you were licensed or
not but how many mistakes would have to
happen for them to learn
that and so your your thought is that we
would have to that in order to a to
avoid that risk we should have this
licensing system in place 100% for the
citizens of this great state all right
other questions yes Mr yes
representative D Lorenzo thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question um as far as your certification
um are you administered an oath as part
of you know being licensed I swear
people in if that's what you're saying I
I don't take an oath I I give an oath I
administer an oath to Witnesses okay
which is granted to me under the LCR as
well so that's a I'm also a notary but I
don't have to be a notary but that's not
my question I'm I'm asking you if you
are required to um take an oath of
office uh with for confidentiality or
anything like that nope that's just
inherent in the rules of the ethical
rules of following the state okay
guidelines may I follow yes of course so
then let's talk about the ethical rules
those come from the state is that
it that's part of the LCR what is the
LCR the licensed court reporter that's
the licensed court reporter so through
the licensed court reporter organization
whatever they are you take an oath of
office I don't go somewhere like in in
the notary office and raise my hand to
do that all right I get that oh so I
meant I didn't mean like o the I said
this what about the um ethics that
you're required to um subscribe to do
you swear to um that's part of follow
the ethical code yes it's it's part of
the cope of um code of professional
ethics okay that we follow it's called
cope okay and follow up and that's not a
government entity right that is a
commercial entty they follow the
national court reporters Association
okay as well okay so they're a
commercial rather than governmental yes
okay they're private thank you all right
representative Alexander please thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking my
question are you held liable for
Distributing personal information
whether you're licensed or not could you
be held liable absolutely we oh sorry go
ahead no I just I I guess I'm I'm a
bartender by trade like I sling beers at
night um Bud Lights whatever you know so
um do you have any on you not not
currently hopefully later so um my
question is is I am not licensed at all
I don't have to be licensed but I am
liable so what you're saying is like the
license is so important because you
could you know share personal
information or whatever but I'm liable
if I serve somebody too many drinks and
they drive so I guess I'm wondering is
like how critical is the license itself
to protecting the liability or personal
information of the person you're you're
taking a deposition from so you're
comparing bartender to to court reporter
well I'm I'm comparing an unlicensed
position to a licensed position what's
the difference between the two in the
liability aspect there's no
accountability to an unlicensed
person there there's no we have a
assurity bond that we have to carry as
part of our LCR that protects us um so
I'm I'm so to follow up I think I think
I got a contradiction because I heard
once that you are liable if you share
somebody's personal information if
you're not licensed you're still liable
for sharing personal information oh if
that's how what I answered I apologize I
I if you're not licensed what what's the
recourse they'd have to sue me
personally I
guess okay I just wouldn't be held to a
governmental standard and and wouldn't
be reprimanded wouldn't lose my lure
wouldn't lose my
certifications all those things that I
hold deer in doing my job okay right
representative
ston do you carry uh professional
liability
insurance we are available we can get um
Eno insurance but we it's covered under
our shity
bond that we're required to have and um
to get that you know professional
liability must you be licensed according
to the insurance company's uh provisions
on the policy issue I am unsure of that
question I know that I get the shity
bond because I'm
licensed thank
you representative
K is there something in the licensing
rules that somewhere states
that you're only liable up to the $1,000
shity Bond that's a good question I will
defer to Megan she's very familiar with
all the um the sections section 310
thank you
other questions for this witness seeing
none thank you very much thank you next
please good afternoon chairman Lynn nice
to see you again same here members of
the committee if I slip and call you
your honor you'll understand we've had a
long history together going back uh many
years uh I am proud to be New Hampshire
Li since court reporter number 61 and I
live in Northampton New Hampshire on the
Sea Coast which was a lot warmer than up
here little 48 degrees before I hit the
road to come here today um Katherine
deferred a few questions to me and uh
there are some other things I'd like to
mention as well but let me start with
the last one the shity bond question uh
representative um it is
$1,000 and there is no higher limit that
we're required to get pursuant to our
licensure with the RSA uh I suppose we
could um I personally do not carry uh
professional liability insurance Eno
insurance I never have uh I I never saw
the need for it and nobody's ever come
after me about any bad transcripts or
omissions or acts that I've done so um
that's the answer to that question as
far as the amount that's required by the
RSA um the code of ethics
representative uh
dorenzo uh the code of ethics in the RSA
is tied to the code of ethics of the
national Cory Porters
Association so they go to each other if
we eliminate lure that code of ethics
goes away if we eliminate lure the shity
bond goes away if we eliminate lure the
requirement for continuing education
units which is 10 units 10 hours a year
go goes away um I will say this I think
the greatest deterrent against unethical
maybe even illegal acts by practitioners
in any profession is the possibility of
losing one's license and not being able
to work are you not better drivers
because you were licensed to
drive would you go through that red
arrow and make an illegal act knowing
that you're going to luse your license
if you do so and get caught you probably
don't so I I ask you to consider that
and you I know that you think is the
national certification enough and why
should the state of New Hampshire be
involved be further involved continue to
be involved the marketplace will sort
out who's good and who's bad I would ask
you to also think about not just the
lawyers that we work with on a daily
basis but prosay
litigants I I'm doing a prosay
deposition next week these are folks
that um judge Lin will tell tell you
represent themselves in civil courts and
even criminal courts and I have a
deposition next week and it's a prosay
person who is suing their veterinarian
for medical
negligence so I have to be absolutely
impartial not even the imper of
impropriety dealing and judge you know
how difficult prosay litigant can be um
and they're filling the courts more and
more so it's not just the lawyers that
have to pick the court reporters it's
also individual litigant pray
litigant and so more
things uh the lack of complaints against
practitioners we say yeah whoooo that's
because we do all the things that I've
mentioned the cus the ethics and I'll
tell you with artificial intelligence
got mentioned just briefly but our
National Association and I'll make sure
that all you folks get this has issued a
white paper
about the effect of AI in the in the
judicial system I'll make sure you all
get a copy of this this is very scary
stuff that's happening um our
CEUs we Embrace learning new stuff we
love to learn new stuff not just
technology stuff as far as our sto
machines and software but we are
learning about AI cloud storage issues
data breaches and as court reporters on
a daily basis when we're in very highly
sensitive depositions we have to sign
non-confidentiality agreements
non-disclosure agreements we have to
sign on to protective orders a
protective order means that we cannot
talk about let anything come out that
was a document and exhibit a trade
secret all the information that
Katherine mentioned we are privy to
Social Security numbers birth dates
mother's maiden names and when the
attorneys start to go down that road and
and ask somebody their name their
address and then they hit the birth date
and then they they want the social
security number it's us as court
reporters that say councel could we
please stop and go off the Record
because that is going to violate a
person's personal identify personally
identifiable information and the lawyers
are learning they go off the Record they
get the Social Security while we're off
the Record so it's not in our
transcripts and then they go back on the
record they write it down somewhere but
that that combination of information as
you know can lead to data breaches and
personal uh identity theft so those are
things to consider um you haven't
brought up some things but uh I I think
we're so far over time I I just would
not answer any questions you want
questions for this
witness yes representative
please thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question um so when
I'm looking at the national court
reporters Association we website I'm
just I'm trying to differentiate I guess
what the difference between the NC is
and the difference between the New
Hampshire I'm just I'm not understanding
why you need the New Hampshire
certification when I'm seeing on there
that they do require a certain number of
continuing add-on here and that there is
a process uh for filing a complaint
against the member of the association
could the RSA just not state that a
court reporter has to be certified by
the NC and then just eliminate the
license couldn't the statute just simply
be amended that you have to be a member
of this National Organization in good
standing I don't think you can force
membership and a voluntary membership
organization and there are
lenses that are I don't know about that
I mean the bar is a is a private
organization and we force attorneys to
be members of
that excuse me um um with all due
respect the bar is a holy own subsidiary
of the Supreme Court it is not an
independent body we're we're one of we
are one of it's called unified bar
unified bar we are we are I think
there's a minority of states that have
unified bars but we are one of them
Massachusetts is not for example but in
New Hampshire if you want to practice
law you have to be a member of the of
the bar but okay but in so in
Massachusetts it's privately owned and
to be a mass attorney you have to be a
member of the bar right right but you
don't have to be a member of the bar
association you don't have to be
Association that's
okay thank you for the question other
other
questions yes representative tur please
uh just in in the in the broader sense
um your
Association consists completely of um
licensed court reporters is that right
is there I I guess what I'm what I'm
wondering is do you have the the
knowledge of is is essentially everyone
impacted by this this um uh potential
withdrawal of a license supportive of
the license the way that it currently
exists at least as as as sort of your
organization um promotes that oh to
answer your question we have also
retired members and we also have a
student member uh because uh student
we're doing some great work on the local
and National level of recruiting and
training court reporters for the future
and so it's not just licensed court
reporters but we have retired members
and a student member and we have an
associate member or two these are people
that proof read like for instance I am
use a a proofreader that I give a 1099
to every year and uh I she proofreads
every transcript of mine so after I
finish producing the transcript I proof
freed it myself but we all know how many
times we Blow by our own errors so I pay
an outside person who is a retired
licensed court reporter and she proof
freed all my work
can I just just one quick follow of
course uh thanks that that's helpful so
so in your knowledge there's nobody sort
of within your Association asking to
remove the licensing requirement there's
there's is do you ever hear of anyone
saying this shouldn't shouldn't I
shouldn't be forced to do this I've not
heard anyone wanting to do that and if
here yes representative stap I'm curious
um how do you become a court reporter do
you have um instruction training uh a
degree course uh what what are the
parameters for becoming a qualified
reporter I can answer it personally um
and generally personally I have an
associates degree in court and
Conference reporting um I graduated from
high school in
1976 and I graduated from college in
1978 with my associates degree degree in
courton conference reporting from Mass
Bay Community College in Massachusetts
where I'm originally from um so
obviously you know I am now 65 years old
or I was a child prodigy cour reporter
one or the other so I've been doing this
47 years and I still love it and uh just
got my Medicare card and I'm still
working because that's how much I love
this job I love this profession I love
this career but it's a 2-year generally
a 2-year program some people want to go
four years and get a bachelor's degree U
some people do it private training
through
individuals uh and there are some very
talented natural Steno writers out there
that can complete a course in much
shorter time but I wanted to get my
associates degree and have that degree
so I did a full curriculum for two
years y other questions for this witness
seeing none thank you very much thank
you jine thank
you uh is there anyone else who wishes
1412 of course representative leakas
up um this addresses the question of
whether the state can require somebody
of a member of a private organization
currently in order to get a license uh
to become a court reporter you are
required to join at least one of the two
organizations that are on the
application you have there so that's
currently law and uh and if if the
committee I don't think there's a need
for the license the people employing
them can require the certification but
if the committee felt more comfortable
uh just saying if you're going to uh
practice as a court reporter you have to
have one of these certifications of
course that that would be not
unreasonable thing to do thank
you yes um I'm sorry please if you had a
response to that go happy to hear
it yes thank you so much um I think
representative Lea said that we're
required to be members of Our National
Association that actually is not the
case um there are licensed court
reporters who are not members of Our
National Association they got their lure
either through the grandfathering from
decades ago or because they came here
from another state and had licensed from
another state and held the What's called
the registered professional reporter
designation from our National
Association called the rpr but our RSA
currently you have to have the rpr to
apply and get your license here but you
do not have to maintain that status
after you get your license
here right other questions for this
witness thank you thank you judge all
right anyone else who wishes to be heard
on
hb142 seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on hb1 1412 and I will open the
hearing on HB
Alexander
I'm sorry Mr chair I'll fill out a pink
card in a minute um for the record my
name is Joe Alexander I represent the
town of will not impose any demerits on
you for not having kill it out in
advance thank youex um I'm introducing
this on behalf of my colleague
representative Traer um I got a text
message from him last night I will read
it
verbatim Joe would you please present
hb1 1252 and ask for itl 1252 or 1251
hope 1251 1251 okay all right this bill
okay and with that I'm ending my
testimony thank you all right all right
um and I I should note just for the
record um I I ran into uh uh I believe
it was representative to trer who was uh
I think in involved in some other she
who who had some other business here
today was not able to be here but who
who basically who told me the same thing
um and I had a discussion with uh
with uh him last evening uh about the
bill and I I told him I expressed
personally that I had some reservations
about the the uh the idea of having a
police officer be able to uh practice
law uh other than maybe as a prosecutor
and and I think he he he would sort of
shared my view and and indicated that he
was going to ask that the billb itl um
so in light of that um and in the
interest of uh of getting as many bills
out as possible I wonder if if
representative Smith would
be oh yeah yes I will anybody else that
wishes to be heard on hb1
1251 seeing none I will close the
hearing on that and representative Smith
would you uh be interested in if we uh
agreeing to an itl of this bill I I
would be agreeable to the
committee I'm agreeable as the ranking
member to the committee voting on the
bill now all right great um so
representative Alexander if I repres
recognize you for a motion sure uh Mr
chair I move HB 1251 be found
inexpedient to legislate is there a
second second second by representative
Wallace um anyone wish to be heard uh on
this right then I think we're uh ready
to call the role I would ask uh call the
role Vice chairman Wallace yes rep
Alexander yes rep testerman yes rep
Stapleton
yes rep trip yes rep gson yes clerk tab
votes yes rep Smith yes rep dorenzo yes
rep Divine yes rep lonza yes rep Manos
oh sorry repur
yes um uh chairman Lynn yes motion
passes 13
to0 uh consent yes assume all right and
Mr chair if you don't mind I'll defer
you to writing the report I'll be happy
[Laughter]
report all
right all right any uh any other
adjourn I don't all right I don't think
so so I guess we'll adjourn thank you
everyone and uh we'll see
you uh next next Wednesday yes next oh
Fray Friday for for some of us but yes
everyone